[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement Victor ?
Bien sûr. Victor Poucher àur éthique et
aujourd'hui directeur technique chez BZ
Don.
Brissograas. Euh je ne suis pas un
cybercriminel mais je suis à cœur
éthique et je suis président de BZent.
Bienvenue à la maison.
Merci.
Bon aujourd'hui on va parler hacking au
21e siècle, cybersécurité, poutrage,
faille de sécurité, la totale. On va
commencer par donner une définition.
Quelle est la différence entre hackur et
pirate qui s'y colle ?
Je la celle-là.
Si on va se renvoyer la balle toute la
soirée, ça commence.
Alors, il y a
Soyez pas timide. Il y a la réalité des
faits. La réalité des faits, c'est ce
qu'on lit dans la presse aujourd'hui où
encore
euh on traîne les casseroles historique
où dès lors qu'il y a une problématique
de cybersécurité, un incident de
sécurité, les mots qui sont employés,
ils ont leur et ils ont leurs
importances, ils sont encore trop
employés à tort. Et par cela, je
voudrais dire que bah
le hackur éthique le hackur le hackur
n'est pas un pirate informatique, le
hackur n'est pas un cybercriminel. Donc
on a encore dans dans nos étiquettes et
les casseroles constraînent finalement
cette vision négative du sujet. Euh on
n'est pas enfin le aujourd'hui nous on
se considère comme à cœur et ce qu'on
réalise on le fait dans un contexte
légal éthique.
Tes frères te considèrent comme ça ?
Comment
tes frères te considèrent comme ça ?
Pas que mes frères, les visions
changent. Heureusement maintenant le
toutvenant aussi commence à s'y
intéresser. Les entreprises aussi
commencent à nous considérer comme des
hackurs. Nous font confiance dans le
sens où c'est légal, c'est cadré. Donc
historiquement, ouais, par contre,
ouais, c'était plus communautaire
finalement, c'était une vision, un état
d'esprit, ça le reste, mais dans la
manière dont la perception la perception
du sujet et la démystification du alors
on est dans le cliché, on est venu en en
suite à capuche, mais
mais on est on est aussi un peu dans la
provoque et l'autodérision, mais le le
cliché vraiment du hackur et tu tapes
sur enfin, tu ouvres Google, tu tapes,
tu fais Google image et tu as la
tendance de ce qui ressort finalement
C'est ça qui est assez criant de la
manière dont c'est perçu. Donc le hacker
n'est pas un cybercriminel qui est dans
l'illégalité, n'est pas un pirate
informatique qui lui aussi est dans
l'illégalité. Et comme on en parlait
tout à l'heure, c'est le sujet du cors
et là je me dédoine, je te refile le
bébé. Allez hop.
On a pu échanger là-dessus à ce sujet
tout à l'heure, mais effectivement le
corser lui agit sur ordre du roi et
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est une
excellente analogie avec la le le
distingo que on essaie de faire que l'on
se doit de faire aujourd'hui entre le
cybercriminel et le hackur éthique.
Là-dessus,
si on son si on si on doit vraiment
faire le distingo, c'est est-ce que
aujourd'hui on a des on a des
mercenaires, on a des entités étatiques
? Est-ce qu'on a des Est-ce qu'on a des
on a simplement des gangs de criminels ?
C'est c'est un écosystème qui est
extrêmement complexe et qui lui doit
être réellement séparé de ceux qui ont
alors je je vais me permettre de faire
un anglicisme de ceux qui ont
aujourd'hui le mindset, l'état d'esprit
du hacking et pour moi ça c'est une
seconde partie justement de cette
composante qu'il faut aujourd'hui
vraiment souligner, c'est que même si
aujourd'hui on parle d'informatique
d'IT, ce terme de de hacker de hacking
lui remonte alors moi si je me trompe
mais il me semble il remonte jusqu'aux
années 70 avec les les premiers
passionnés du club de train du MIT.
Potentiellement, je je fais une erreur
sur l'étologie exacte du terme, mais
l'idée initiale, c'était d'être capable
de faire plus avec moins de soulever des
des de solutionner des problèmes
complexes de manière élégante. Et donc
cet état d'esprit aujourd'hui, peut être
appliqué quel que soit le domaine sur
lequel on souhaite souhaite exercer, que
ce soit aujourd'hui sur l'informatique,
que ce soit sur la finance, que ce soit
sur la croissance, que ce soit sur les
relations humaines, c'est être capable
de voir les choses autrement.
Les meubles IKEA.
Oui. Oui, exactement.
Les meubles IKEA. IK Abidouille, tu
connais ou pas ? Ben voilà. Ben c'est un
état d'esprit en fait. C'est
Non, c'est c'est
c'est exactement ça. Voilà. Et l'idée
c'est voilà comment est-ce qu'on
approche les problèmes avec une avec une
un état d'esprit, une approche
innovante. Comment est-ce qu' est
capable alors le terme anglais une fois
de plus, désolé pour les anglicismes, le
think outside of the box.
Penser en dehors de la boîte.
Exactement. penser comment est-ce qu'on
pense en dehors de la boîte, comment
est-ce qu'on a une approche différente
et au final comment est-ce qu'on est
capable de résoudre soit des problèmes
de la vie tous les jours, soit des
problèmes avancé avec cette cette
approche un petit peu en norme.
Euh Bris, est-ce que tu te rappelles ?
Alors vous êtes tous les deux très
jeunes par rapport à nous.
Je le prends comme un compliment parce
que j'ai pas dit mon âge. Brisque, tu as
quel âge ?
J'ai 30 ans.
Victor, tu veux donner ton âge ou pas ?
J'en ai 24. Non mais ça c'est ce que tu
dis pour rentrer en boîte de nuit ça.
Tu vas avoir toutes les tentatives de
réunite de mot de passe avec notre le
donc bon il faut éviter de faire trop pr
joke parce que sinon on va se faire
tirer les oreilles. Comment t'expliques
en fait la différence de perception
entre la France et l'Allemagne avec les
hackers ? Est-ce que tu t'es tu t'es
bien posé la question que pourquoi en
France nous on était considéré comme des
délinquants et que et que en Allemagne
beaucoup moins et les services de
renseignement allemand ont commencé à
moissonner dans les hackers bien avant
la France. Est-ce que tu te rappelles ce
qui s'est passé avec la France quand les
services commençaient à à essayer de
nous approcher ?
Alors
je je vais pas pouvoir répondre à tout.
Par contre, je peux m' je peux me
souvenir de la manière dont dont bah
dont j'ai grandi avec le hacking et
comment j'ai vu la perception évoluer au
bah entre l'étape de l'adolescence et
les la première découverte de la passion
pour l'informatique et je dirais mon
statut et le métier que j'en ai
aujourd'hui. Donc ça je vais pouvoir
faire un retour d'expérience. la
comparaison avec l'Allemagne, la culture
underground et vraiment qui est ancrée
et enfin c'est enfin je dirais pas que
c'est une pop culture mais enfin c'est
si c'est de la culture populaire d'une
certaine manière au niveau du hacking.
J'ai pas assez d'éléments pour mettre en
opposition de phase et répondre à ta
question sur les services de
renseignement ont réagi comme ça parce
que je l'ai pas vécu non plus. Euh et
finalement c'est plus à travers des
retours d'expérience de la génération de
10 ans en avant
en en arrière sur laquelle aujourd'hui
ben euh l'étape à laquelle on en est
arrivé aujourd'hui, bah on n' pas vécu
cette partie-là, on n' pas grandi avec.
Euh par contre c'est plutôt ceux qui
l'ont vécu avant qui qui sauraient
l'exprimer qui sauraient l'exprimer.
Mais en l'occurrence le hacking, on a
dans la manière de le percevoir déjà
quand j'étais ado, je j'aurais je
n'aurais jamais imaginé que ça aurait
qu'un jour j'aurais pu en faire un
métier d'une part. Euh de deux, je j'ai
grandi avec et en faisant des études à
côté, mais même chose, c'était
poursuivre mon cursus scolaire bien
cadré, euh
brillant. Non, ça on en rediscutera.
Mais tu as été déscolarisé ?
J'ai pas alors j'ai pas été déscolarisé.
J'ai arrêté j'ai rashquit mon école
d'ingeter. Euh au lycée, j'ai eu une
phase compliquée où j'ai redoublé et
j'ai été exclu.
Euh c'est l'anecdote, je ferai l'impasse
dessus mais euh parce que effectivement
j'arrivais à un stade où dans le cursus
d'apprentissage
euh on éétait pas sur le sur le genre de
sensation que me procurait le hacking et
à l'époque je le rappelle c'était pas de
l'illégalité, c'était de la passion
technique, le fait de créer, de faire
les choses différemment, d'apprendre
comprendre
comprendre le la ça a toujours été la
politique du RTFM quoi. Read the fucking
manual, je ne sais pas quelque chose où
Victor aujourd'hui, enfin tous les gars
de la commue partagent ses valeurs.
C'est je suis face à une à une boîte
noire.
Je ne sais je sais comment elle
fonctionne de manière très standard et
telle qu'on attend. J'ai envie de faire
ça avec. Il faut déjà que je me
l'approprie que je la comprenne avant de
détourner son fonctionnement. Et c'est
ça qui me manquait dans le cursus
scolaire. Euh je l'ai retrouvé un peu en
DUT postback parce que c'était très
technique. J'avais fait un DUT GO2 à
l'époque donc c'était informatique
électronique, tu touchais, tu
concrétisais et après tu posais les
bases théoriques et c'était kiffant
parce que au final tu savais pourquoi tu
apprenais et au final dans le hacking
c'est un peu ça c'est je me plante,
j'essaie, je casse et à partir de là je
je me construis un modèle
d'apprentissage ou un modèle théorique.
et en école d'inget après ça a été un
carnage parce que au final on revenait
sur une approche
trop cadrée.
Je je considérais pas en bac plus 2 tu
vois typiquement et j'étais très axé
diplôme à l'époque mais je considérais
pas être un expert technique parents ça
c'était tes parents
regarde ce soir je pense mais d'une
certaine manière oui. Pourquoi ? parce
que c'était inscrit dans le dans le dans
le point de vue collectif et de la
société finalement, c'est fais des fais
des études, passe ton diplôme, tu veux
devenir tu veux te spécialiser dans
l'informatique, deviens ingénieur
informatique. Je pousse le trait de la
caricature mais on en est pas si loin
que ça. Et
la chanson
non,
ingénieur informaticien
ou là je connais
je connais je code avec le cul aussi.
Pardon
Victor, tu as fini ? Euh j'ai bientôt
fini et euh du coup effectivement bah
euh le hacking bah ça a été euh
finalement une une activité de passion
extra pro extrascolaire euh et c'est
finalement un peu par accident et à
force de persévérer en en allant en
mettant des coups de pieds dans la
formulière que ça a pu euh devenir une
activité professionnelle. Voilà,
Victor.
Alors, effectivement au niveau du
background, c'est vrai que alors même si
initialement nos nos deux background
partent pas forcément vraiment des des
mêmes points de départ, ils se
rejoignent à un moment dans l'histoire
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
on est aujourd'hui ici tous les deux.
Euh c'est assez différent. De mon côté,
j'ai eu accès à des à des ordinateurs et
assez tard, de façon assez tardive. J'ai
24 ans, j'ai eu j'ai pu avoir accès à un
ordinateur, je pense tour des 14 15 ans.
C'est quel modèle ? Quel langage ?
Ou c'était un Alors, je crois que le
alors non effectivement ça va être très
factuel. J'ai pu jouer à Pong sur un
vieux MacBook sur lequel on faut encore
insérer des floppy disques de des
disquettes de 3.5 3.5 M.
Encore envie de me donner un coup de
vieux là. C'est ça. Vas-y continue.
Non attends c'était c'était c'était
ça sur ça.
Ça commence avec MSN je crois.
CPC
tu me parles en catégorie, je comprends.
Non, par contre effectivement là où j'ai
vraiment pu mettre les pour la pour la
première fois les mains sur du code,
c'était plus en tour de mes 14 15 ans et
à l'époque quand j'ai formulé de façon
très naïve mes intentions à ma famille,
ils ont compris qu'il y avait un ils ont
compris qu'il y avait un entre un
risque. Et effectivement, de manière
tout à fait légitime à l'époque, on
avait déjà les prémisses de des hackur
qui essayent de faire des des des
remontées de vulnérabilité auprès de
soit d'entreprise so d'entités diverses
et qui effectivement avaient des pour
judiciaires. Et donc sur le le le modèle
de pensée que pouvait se faire ma
famille ou moi-même à l'époque, c'était
voilà effectivement le métier
d'accurtique c'est réservé à une
peut-être une très fine franche de la
population qui peut en vivre et encore
c'est dangereux. Bon euh si on fait un
petit un petit une petite avancée assez
rapide, peu d'accès sur les animateurs,
vous débrouiller pour bidouiller avec ce
qu'on avait des téléphones, des
calculatrices, ce qu'on avait sous la
main.
TI92 ou 82, c'est ça ?
Ah oui, la TI82 qui était complètement
programmable.
Tu pouvais jouer à Doom en réseau avec
le cap d'échange de données.
Ah,
c'était c'était incroyable. C'était
incroyable. et puis les l'apparition des
premiers smartphones sur lesquels on
pouvait déployer un Linux qui a permis
beaucoup de vraiment de s'approprier le
système. J'ai passé les concours de
pharma médecine
donc j'avais 17 ans et demi
19 de moyenne
à l'époque. Non du tout là on arrive à
l'escroquerie mais c'est juste pépite.
Allez-y les gars.
Alors effectivement donc j'avais une
appétence pour la tech j'avais une
appétence aussi pour la santé. Bon, sans
doute du cade familial, famille accès
très axé pharma et et médecine. Donc la
voix était toute tracée. Euh je me suis
retamé la première année. Bon, c'était
aussi la première année où j'étais un
petit peu plus libre et où j'ai commencé
à redécouvrir les ordinateurs. La
seconde, j'ai raté pharma à trois places
et je me suis rattrapé inextrémiste
parce que je me dis bon c'est bon, on
est lancé, on est formaté, on continue,
on va faire une carrière dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique, on va on va
être cade pour l'industrie.
Donc continuons. J'ai pu j'ai pu
atterrir dans une école d'ingénieur de
la faculté de pharmacie de Montpellier
puis j'ai fait mes études et puis c'est
quand quand on a un premier amour, on
finit toujours par y revenir.
Donc je faisais mes études, j'essayais
de pas toucher c'est le la boîte de
Pandore. Puis j'y revenais puis j'y
allais puis j'ai revenais. J'ai
découvert le le bug Bunti, la prime à la
feuille. Je pense qu'on évoquera un
petit peu plus tard là-dessus. C'est ça
a été vraiment la première étape en tout
cas vers vers la professionnalisation de
de cette activité là en tant que en tant
que jeune étudiant. Et puis finalement
au bout de au bout de 5 ans, un diplôme
de master 2 en poche, ingénieur de la
santé, spécialisation marketing pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique et une
promesse d'embauche dans une dans une
dans une multinationale pharmaceutique
au siège monde. J'ai fini par dire en
fait non, je veux pas, c'est pas ce que
c'est pas ce que j'aime faire, c'est pas
c'est pas le cœur de ce que je veux
faire. Et à l'époque, j'ai proposé j'ai
proposé à ma compagne de partir écoute,
on va se louer un appartement en
Espagne, on va faire le tour du monde
puis on va on va jouer au casino et puis
on va on va faire du bug buunty et puis
on va faire le tour du monde comme ça.
Et puis j'ai rencontré Wis,
vous êtes marié.
C'est ce que répondraient nos femmes.
Ouais. Là à l'heure actuelle, c'est bon,
on a passé un peu trop de temps à la
maison avant de partir.
Et en fait, oui, c'est moi-même, on
s'est rencontré sur des sur des
plateformes de bug bountti. Donc aussi
une plateforme.
Effectivement, ouais, si je peux me
permettre de vulgariser rapidement, tu
me dis si tu veux. Tranqu. Alors l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est euh la réalisation
d'un d'un test d'intrusion de
du coup de de la réalisation d'un d'un
HAC entre guillemets sur une entreprise.
Ça peut se faire de via un contrat de
prestation de services tout à fait
standard de sociétés qui parlent entre
elles, qui mettent à disposition une
expertise technique, un savoir-faire à
disposition d'une autre entreprise. Et
en fait euh sur ce modèle de ce modèle
traditionnel euh a émergé un nouveau
modèle basé selon moi, en tout cas sur
déjà l'activité de la communauté.
C'est-à-dire que des personnes qui
n'étaient pas forcément professionnelles
mais qui avaient cette appétence cyber
étaient capable de remonter des
vulnérabilités, d'en détecter sur les
sites qu'ils utilisaient au quotidien.
Et ces personnes-là souhaitaient de
manière citoyenne faire remonter ces
problématiques sécuritaires sans
demander quoi que ce soit en
contrepartie.
Euh si on revient 10 ans en arrière,
c'était un petit peu plus compliqué
parce qu'on avait pas le cas de légal à
l'époque. Bon, je je fais la la
microparenthèse, mais je vais la fermer
très rapidement. Euh donc à l'époque,
c'était pas possible de pouvoir remonter
ces vulnérabitales là de manière éthique
euh avec donc les pionniers en tout cas
de de de la cybersécurité en France, les
les hackurs éthiques. parce que tout à
l'heure la la génération qui était juste
avant nous en tout cas et qui est qui
est toujours là aujourd'hui et qui
contribue à apporter en tout cas la
communauté qui l'a amené en partie enfin
en grande partie là où elle est
aujourd'hui ont contribué à implémenter
voir ont créé les premières plateformes
de Bugby Buunty. Alors justement
qu'est-ce que c'est le club Bugby Buunty
? Aujourd'hui, vous êtes
cadre dans l'industrie pharmaceutique
avant avant avant Bug Bunti, pourquoi on
dit bug Bunti ? Alors, Bug Bunti,
traduction française fran enfin version
francisée plutôt euh prime à la faille
chasseur de prix.
Chasseur de
Mais tu sais pourquoi on dit ?
Ah bah comme les comme aux US quoi les
chasseurs de prime qui eux par contre
ne trouvent pas des failles mais ils
trouvent des gens enfin des criminels
c'est sur le même modèle finalement.
Ouais. Absolument. Et donc l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est de mettre en relation
une entreprise avec alors encore un
terme anglais mais un pool donc une
piscine des des ressources humaines des
des hackurs et c'est cette notion de
hackur est vraiment à prendre au sens
large. C'estàd que ça peut être aussi
bien quelqu'un qui est un professionnel
de la cybersécurité que en fait un
passionné, un étudiant peu importe un
bidouilleur. Exactement. Et au final, à
cœur, c'est peut-être enfin c'est
peut-être la meilleure traduction
française du terme à cœur, c'est
l'aspect bidouilleur. qu'aujourd'hui il
y a des entreprises qui dans au sein de
leur processus de sécurité, au sein de
leur évolution et et certaines
entreprises en fait ont obtenu un niveau
de maturité suffisant pour pouvoir se
permettre et même demander à des hackurs
de venir travailler sur leur site, sur
certains de leurs applicatifs et
aujourd'hui le le bug s'étend vraiment
au-delà des au-delà des des frontières
des des sites web et invite les hackurs
à leur faire des des rapports de
vulnérabilité sur des problématiques
sécuritaire qui peuvent avoir trouvé en
échange de quoi ? Ouais. En échange de
quoi ? En fait, on peut avoir une
rémunération, une graphification
financière
de l'argent. Ouais, exact.
Alors là, je vais vous poser Tu as fini
Victor ?
Oui. Oui, je t'en prie.
Je vais vous poser une question éthique.
Ouais.
C'est quoi un black hat et pourquoi il y
a des black hat ?
Un blackat, c'est un pirate informatique
ou un cybercriminel. Donc quelqu'un avec
des compétences techniques dans le
milieu de l'informatique euh et de la
sécurité informatique, sauf qu'il les
utilise dans un contexte d'illégalité.
Ils réalisent des actions malveillantes
aujourd'hui dans dans les exemples types
qui ressortent le plus et qui sont le
plus médiatisés mais aussi le plus
observable, c'est tout ce qu'on voit,
les attaques paromware
qui font la une de la presse, les fuites
de données comme on l'a encore lu la
semaine dernière. Ça d'ailleurs c'est du
du côté de la de la PHP de Paris par
exemple ces exempl enfin c'est les
acteurs à l'origine de ces actions sont
dans l'illégalité réalisent des actes
malveillants. Par définition c'est la
définition de ce qui un blackat. L
J'ai oublié la deuxième partie de la
question.
Pourquoi il y en a ?
Pourquoi il y en a ? Euh pourquoi il y
en a ? Parce que bah leur motivation
euh qui ressortent. Alors, je veux pas
prendre la la parole à leur place, mais
il y a je pense qu' en élément de en
élément de qui qui pousse à faire ce
choix, il y a la pas du gain. Il y a
aussi un contexte historique parce que
on aime bien philosophier dessus, mais
on a grandi avec
on avait on a grandi sans savoir ce
qu'était le la cœur éthique, sans savoir
qu'on pouvait en faire un job un jour et
finalement, on a eu cette chance. H la
frustration qu'on a pu vivre à l'époque
euh époque d'érance professionnelle euh
et il faut pas dire errance
professionnelle.
C'est vrai ?
Non.
Pourquoi ?
C'est péjoratif.
Bah je l'ai
tu cherchais ta voix.
Bah je le savais mais je ne savais pas
quoi en faire en fait. C'est il y avait
de ça. Ouais c'était je je sais que j'ai
des compétences mais je ne sais pas à
profit de qui je peux les mettre à
disposition. Euh je le faisais
d'ailleurs même pas je le faisais de
manière citoyenne et bénévole juste pour
occuper mes journées et ça m'apportait
rien de positif. Je sans parler de
l'aspect financier. Ouais effectivement
c'était juste en terme de retombée et du
coup le passage à enfin certains membres
qu'on a pu croiser et avec qui on a
grandi, on a échangé sur les chat ont
fait ce choix de bascule. Alors
effectivement, ça reflète peut-être pas
le cliché du pirate informatique russe,
mais par contre russe
hein. J'ai dit cliché avant.
Nor coréen. Vas-y.
J'ai dit cliché. Mais tu vois ce choix
de il y a eu un moment où je pense on a
eu de la enfin on a eu de la chance et
on s'est accroché à cette éthique euh ça
a pas été des étapes faciles de la vie
et finalement d'autres ont ne l'ont pas
fait ce choix et ont préf préféré
s'orienter du mauvais côté pour pour la
ref Star Wars. Donc ils sont dans
l'illégalité, ils sont devenus blackat
même s ils n'étaient pas prédisposés ou
lorsqu'ils ont commencé à s'intéresser
au hacking. Et finalement cette passion,
cette curiosité, cette envie d'apprendre
à l'époque la question de faire le choix
de de sombrer sur sur ces traverses,
elle se posait même pas en fait. C'est
finalement à force d'alimenter la
frustration euh une forme de dégoût
aussi pour euh pour le monde
professionnel peut-être trop cadré sur
certains sujets. Euh il faut aussi noter
le manque de maturité qu'on avait en
France vis-à-vis de la cybersécurité où
effectivement c'est finalement tous ces
grands rebonds médiatiques qu'on porté
avec une mise qu'on porté à la mise en
conformité progressive. C'est aussi des
monté en puissance comme l'ANSI. Mais ça
à l'époque, il y avait pas et la
bascule, elle pouvait se faire bah
beaucoup plus facilement euh lorsqu'on
était sur un équilibre fragile
finalement parce que on voyait pas
d'avenir, on n'imaginait pas un métier.
Alors pour moi effectivement et même
pour complémenter et quitte à sortir un
petit peu du cadre du du scope comme
comment comme comment comme on le dit.
Euh l'une des l'une des questions en
fait qu'on qu'on peut se poser de
manière complémentaire, elle rejoint
vraiment le domaine alors un de l'aspect
sociétal et donc de de l'utilisation
d'une d'une compétence particulière qui
n'arrive pas à rentrer dans le cadre de
la société et deux justement on celle
presque de la criminologie de la
psychologie de du du criminel. C'estàd
que aujourd'hui comment intégrer un
individu dans la société dont le
meilleur jeu de compétences ne s'intègre
pas dans un cadre conventionnel ? Et
alors cette cette question là elle
s'applique aux deux côtés de la force
plus pour la référence Star Wars.
C'estàd que vous avez vous vous
retrouvez avec un individu qui a des
compétences techniques, qui ne sait pas
quoi en faire, qui se retrouve séparé
entre une vie pour mettre dans le cliché
rigoureuse, bien cadrée et qui suit son
titre in train quotidien et celle de la
promesse de l'aventure des et de
l'argent. Pomp
comment
pompé ? Oui, c'est ça. Et en fait voilà
comment en fait on est capable
d'intégrer ces individusl. Et
aujourd'hui, nous on a eu la chance de
alors d'avoir à l'époque déjà décidé de
pas faire le de pas faire le mauvais
choix. Une fois plus qu' plus on est
engagé et plus on est dans un dans dans
un dans un cercle criminel dont il va
être difficile de s'en sortir. Tu as été
approché ?
Oui.
Par qui ?
Oh alors pour être très pour être très
franc, j'étais pas enfin j'ai jamais été
particulièrement actif. euh de ce
côté-là, mais en l'occurrence pour
vraiment pour être très factuel, c'était
"Ah bah tiens, il y a un copain sur un
forum sur internet puis ah bah tiens,
est-ce que ça te dit d'aller regarder ce
soir tel site ?" Et infineré, bon ben
très bien, on était on était adolescent
et puis bah qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
deux adolescents sur un site web dans la
nuit et puis derrière bah il y a eu a il
y a eu le il y a eu la la mise en
perspective c'estàd qu'une fois qu'une
action est réalisée derrière c'est en
fait il y a des il y a des conséquences
c'estd que on est dans un monde où
l'internet enfin la partie la composante
cyber de notre société est énorme. Elle
permet aujourd'hui, on pourra on pourra
pararler l'actualité de faire tourner
des des pays entiers si on parle des
paremp des supply chain
infrastructure énergétique.
Exactement. Si on a un acteur quelque
part dans dans dans une chaîne qui
tombe, on peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques sur sur une société vraiment
soit un effet domino, soit parfois un
effet papillon parce qu'on aura pas
forcément anticipé l'impact que pouvait
avoir un petit acteur sur un écosystème
global. Et puis et puis même derrière
enfin la la la vie d'agent parce que ce
que je pense ce que beaucoup de
criminels font et oublient de oubli de
regarder, c'est en fait ce sont des sont
des vies humaines derrière un site,
derrière une entreprise, derrière un
numéro de carte bleue. On a un humain,
on a un humain à qui peut-être si on lui
avait parlé, on aimerait pas lui faire
ça, on aimerait pas que ça nous arrive à
nous. Et derrière, il y a une véritable
composante humaine qui est critique et
beaucoup trop ignorée. Je pense.
Tu te retrouves un peu dans le même cas
de figure qu'avec le cyberharcèlement
finalement derrière l'écran, full
puissance, pas conscience des impacts.
Euh par contre quand on se retrouve sur
le terrain en réponse à incident et que
tu vas voir le mec avec sa boîte, tu vas
lui dire "Je suis désolé." Bah au final
vous allez rien récupérer, vous allez
recommencer comme 20 ans en arrière. Ouf
! Sur le plan technique, on sait
apporter l'expertise, on sait être très
factuel et on sait expliquer, déclencher
un processus de gestion de crise. Mais
la solution miracle, on est enfin, il y
a aussi la la faisabilité technique où
si c'est un romware qui s'est mangé, les
sauvegardes ont été supprimées,
réécrasées ou formaté bas niveau, même
si les disques partent dans une société
de récupération spécialisée qui disent
"C'est mort". Derrière, il faut annoncer
que tout est perdu, quoi. Et euh
aujourd'hui, les boîtes ont encore une
telle dépendance à l'outil informatique.
Euh et aussi parce qu'on l'a créé et
qu'on vit comme ça nos jours hein, euh
quand il faut leur annoncer que c'est
fini. Euh cette formation à la gestion
de la crise humaine, nous on sait pas le
faire et par contre aujourd'hui enfin et
on le constate et on doit le faire en
dépit et on n pas été formé pour ça.
On va faire une pause sur le côté
historicité de la culture hacking et
comment c'est opérationnel en ce moment
dans les entreprises. On va parler
géopolitique.
Bah on a pas bien on a pas on a peu
voyagé. On y connaît rien en politique
du coup.
Ouais mais par contre en faille de
sécurité on en connaitt de trois.
Quand vous voyez par exemple Pegasus, un
utilitaire qui a été vendu par une
société qui s'appelle NSO,
qui a été vendue soit-disant à des
gouvernements et que maintenant cet
utilitaire qui permet qui permet de
prendre le contrôle d'un téléphone
portable sur une faille qui d'ailleurs
est relativement facile à activer.
Quand on voit que cinq ministres
français sont potentiellement écoutés,
screenés, capté, captation sonore et je
t'en passe.
Vous de votre côté, ça vous fait quoi en
tant que hackeur français de voir que
notre propre gouvernement est incapable
de mettre des dig pour protéger
peut-être des réseaux, protéger des
informations, protéger des décisions, ne
pas se faire influencer et j'en passe.
Victor,
alors c'est une question qui est assez
complexe là-dessus. Je pense que tu le
enfin tu le sais aussi, on aura pas tous
les éléments enfin d'une partie on aura
pas tous les éléments pour y répondre et
l'autre partie sur les éléments qu'on a
on sera pas forcément en mesure de
communiquer sur l'ensemble de de ceci.
Merci pour ces précautions oratoires
Victor.
Par contre effectivement était devant
un interrogateur policier.
[Musique]
Non mais effectivement ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut dire c'est déjà du point de
vue d'un attaquant et du on va prendre
le monde de manière très binaire. la
blue team, la team, l'attaquant, le
défenseur, le gentil, le méchant si on
veut si on veut vraiment caricaturer
aujourd'hui sur une attaque, il suffit
que l'attaquant gagne une fois et c'est
terminé. Là, le défenseur, lui, do gagné
tous les jours et de manière
perpétuelle.
Ça c'est un premier point de complexité
qui pour moi répond en tout cas à un
sousegment de ta question. Le second
point, c'est lorsqu'on attend simplifier
les choses, on se dit d'accord, très
bien, pourquoi est-ce que ça arrive ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable
de l'arrêter ? D'ailleurs, c'est la
notion de complexité. Euh pour faire une
pour faire une analogie, on prend un
écosystème. D'accord ? Donc par exemple,
on va prendre l'écosystème de la planète
entière. On s'est aperçu aujourd'hui que
si des certaines espèces
disparaissaient, l'écosystème pouvait
être complètement déséquilibré et
s'effondré sur lui-même.
C'est cet effet papillon est difficile
justement à appréhender et aujourd'hui
l'écosystème informatique de de nos
gouvernements, de nos entreprises du de
la planète entière en fait pour moi a ce
même niveau de complexité là. C'estd que
il y a tellement d'acteurs, il y a
tellement de flux de communication, il y
a tellement d'interdépendance
que il y a un travail colossal.
qui est presque hors de en fait presque
hors defin à mon avis en tout à mon
humble opinion est hors de porté d'un
d'un acteur d'une entité unique et c'est
ce point-là je pense qui est le plus
critique aujourd'hui pour répondre à la
à la question de pourquoi est-ce qu'on
arrive pas à pourquoi est-ce qu'on
arrive pas à l'empêcher.
Tu as aussi tu as aussi la partie
souveraineté quand même
aussi la partie humaine.
C'est typiquement enfin sur le sujet
Pegasus.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait pas se poser la
question autrement en disant pourquoi
les ministres utilisent potentiellement
du WhatsApp sur leur mobile Android ?
Euh quelles obligations ont-ils à
utiliser du message de iPhone qui sont
en l'occurrence deux cas d'école.
C'est plus facile pour répondre à sa
maîtresse ?
Je ne suis pas la vie politique mais sur
le choix sur la pertinence du choix
technique là c'est discutable. Euh
surtout répréhensible à ton avis
euh
quand tu vois un ministre quand tu vois
un ministre ne pas utiliser son terminal
sécurisé qu'on se fait chier alors payer
avec nos impôts parce que soit-disant il
est trop gros que machin ils ont pas
leur petite messagerie dessus et que
machin
c'est une bonne question je ne sais bah
la défense des ministres aujourd'hui
alors j'ai oublié l'acronyme c'est c'est
pas l'ANC sur l'aspect sécurité
c'est pas l'ANC l'autorité de régulation
suré la communauté va risque de nous
trouver vas-y pass
mais en l'occurrence l'entité
quel qu'elle soit qui gère la
cyberdéfense
des centres enfin des ministres en
l'occurrence, je ne connais enfin ils
ont des ils émettent des exigences
sécuritaires, ça c'est à peu près sûr en
terme de standard, c'est d'où d'où
l'exemple que tu citais du redescend le
le téléphone à minim chiffré avec
l'écran de enfin le comme sur nos PC les
filtres de confidentialité et j'imagine
des règles de renforcement sécuritaire
au niveau système d'exploitation, au
niveau couche applicative.
Euh pourquoi il y a ce genre de cas
d'usage et est-ce qu'ils sont
répréhendés ? J'en ai aucune idée. Euh
aujourd'hui en tout cas, si je continue
dans si je fais la comparaison, les
entreprises lorsqu'elles manquent à
leurs obligations sécuritaires,
il y a l'ANCY et l'ACNIL qui veilleent
au grain derrière.
Guillaume. Passer un bonjour à
Guillaume.
Ça
et on va faire une expérience de pensée
tous les trois. OK,
on va se dire que
j'ai réussi
à implémenter un Pegasus sur le
ministère de la défense. Le ministre de
la défense.
Je vous mets le cas de figure. J'ai
implémenté le Pegasus sur le ministre,
sa femme, ses enfants, sa femme de
ménage et ses voisins.
Qu'est-ce que je peux faire avec un
Pegasus ? Qu'est-ce que si vous deviez
me contrecarrer faire du forensic sur
une attaque que j'ai faite il y a déjà
de longues années où j'étais bien caché
? Qu'est-ce que j'aurais pu faire avec
le Pegasus en touchant ce biotope là
bien particulier qui est le ministère de
la défense ou ces acolytes la secrétaire
du ministre ou des choses comme ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec un
Pegasus qui peut se révéler dangereux
pour l'État français ?
À partir du moment où euh sur le plan
technique, c'est c'est ce qu'on appelle
une euh remote code execution, hein,
c'est ça permet ni plus ni moins
qu'exécuter de la commande à distance
sur un équipement mobile. Euh au même
titre que lorsqu'on compromet un
serveur, ça permet de bénéficier à
distance de Alors, c'est on pourrait
débattre sur les différents étapes
d'élévation de privilège pour justifier
de effectivement je peux accéder au
micro mais je suis pas tout de suite
super admin route de l'OS Linux. soif
dans tous les cas permet à distance de
bénéficier de l'ensemble des features
qu'on un téléphone qu'à un téléphone.
Donc bah du coup, il y a les
fonctionnalités d'appel, l'appareil
photo, le micro
euh après tout ce qui lié au aux
télécommunications et l'environnement
applicatif qui peut être qui peut être
dessus. Voilà. Donc derrière typiquement
de la messagerie non chiffrée
et ou le cas échant de servir de alors
de de launcher en tout cas de plateforme
pour l'exploitation de nouvelles
vulnérabilités. Par exemple, si on prend
un service de messagerie chiffré X Y Z
euh sur lequel bah dans un dans une
configuration par défaut, on ne pourrait
pas accéder à ces messages là, tu peux
et ben typiquement peut-être en
exploitant une seconde vulnérabilité,
donc on crée vraiment une chaîne de
vulnérabilité, on pourrait accéder à ces
messages là. Donc l'idée vraiment c'est
d'avoir une base de contrôle et de
d'ailleurs de de rebondir sur
toujours dans le conditionnel mais qui
est pas totalement irréaliste non plus.
s'ils ont en par rapport au dossier
Pegasus les vecteurs d'attaque utilisés.
Donc euh c'est ce qu'on appelle des
enfin c'était alors en terme de
chronologie, ça l' plus maintenant mais
c'était des héros dayil à l'époque euh
c'est-à-dire des vulnérabilités
exclusives qui étit maîtrisé par le
groupeuscule ignoré du grand public et
du propriétaire soit de la solution
applicative soit euh soit de la marque
pour la partie iPhone et i message. Donc
ils ont des vecteurs d'attaque au même
titre que d'autres entités de de
renseignement finalement ou de ou autres
étatiques. ces vecteurs d'attaque, rien
n enfin rien n'exclut le fait qu'ils en
aient d'autres et qu'une fois la
compromission du téléphone réalisée, tu
as une capacité de piv donc ce qu'on
appelle de pivoting de rebond
via des protocoles tiers par exemple.
Enfin, typiquement, si j'étais dans ce
cas de figure et je souhaitais étendre
la compromission, je passe par du
Bluetooth et euh enfin Damien Coquille
maîtrise très bien le sujet et il pour
en débattre et exposer les aspects
techniques pendant des heures. Mais
ça veut dire que je peux euh sonoriser
un conseil de ministre
si le bah si le téléphone comprime.
Est-ce qu'ils ont des locaux ? Je ne
connais pas si le la disposition des
locaux sur site. Je sais que tu vois
typiquement Alan téléphone dans une
boîte.
Ouais. Alan 6 et bah Pup a fait un un
super reportage vidéo là-dessus où il
l'illustre concrètement c'est on rentre
en salle de réunion, on rentre en salle
de crise, ça ça vire quoi. Mais du coup,
est-ce que la négligence
connecté aussi les met
euh tout l'oi, tout le bring device, la
clopelec, tout
c'est bien
tout ce qui vient de l'extérieur, tout
outil électronique avec un temps soit
peu d'intelligence informatique
pas artificiel parce que ça
donc revenons à Pegasus. Donc je peux
sonoriser un ministre, je peux prendre
des photos et je peux potentiellement
avoir accès à d'autres téléphones qui
n'avaient pas été encore vérolés. Si on
on pousse un peu le
c'est le principe d'un d'un verre. Alors
sur la sur la réalisabilité technique de
oui très bien, on peut par exemple
utiliser la même vulnérabilité qui nous
a permis d'entrer et de à partir de de
ce point-là renvoyer par exemple des
messages malveillants vers tous les
écosystèmes.
Est-ce que c'est possible de le faire ?
Sans doute. Est-ce que ça a été fait ?
Oui, non, ça par contre on peut pas on
peut pas se prononcer dessus. Mais au
final, l'idée c'est de considérer que
par rapport à un téléphone, on a un
appareil électronique qui est capable de
communiquer avec des ondes, ondes
sonore, onde radio,
de surcommuniquer.
Oui. De surcommuniquer lumière qui est
également une onde. Donc faut considérer
que voilà, c'est un c'est un petit
dispositif qui permet de venir
travailler sur l'ensemble de ces
champs-là. Et donc étant donné que les
ondes radio euh lumineuses, peu importe
et cetera, se diffusent dans un certain
périmètre, effectivement si on veut
vraiment pousser la Panaronoia et le
risque en tout cas que peut offrir un
que peut créer un device, donc un
périphérique compromis. effectivement
bah tout ce qui a apporté radio. Pour ça
que Vladimir Poutine n'a pas de
téléphone portable
sur le plan stratégie d'attaque. Mine de
rien, quand tu tu prends du recul et
vraiment sur le enfin tu on se concentre
sur la technique, c'est quand même le
plus violent en terme d'action. Tu
compromets un poste bureautique fixe, tu
vas pas le balader en salle de réunion.
Là, tu te trimbales avec un truc avec
une belle souche virale que tu mets à
disposition de tout ton écosystème dans
lequel tu évolues. Effectivement, bah
dans ce cas de figure, c'est la sphère
la sphère politique, la sphère
ministérielle et tu te retrouves avec
une potentialité de rebond pour les
attaquants où s'ils ont réussi à sortir
comme ça des zay sur du WhatsApp, enfin
le il y a aussi un moment où enfin ils
ont une ils ont une capacité de bah ça
reste de la RD, c'est terme que ça porte
pour arriver à ce genre d'aboutissement
technique et de et de vecteur d'attaque.
Ils doivent avoir dans leur besace quand
même un certain nombre. Donc le droit à
l'erreur pour moi, il est pas il est pas
possible en fait. C'est tu il est trop
exposant quand quand on a entendu là
récemment
une ministre
où il y a un disque dur qui avait
disparu
physiquement.
J'ai pas suivi ça.
Vous avez pas suivi ça ? J'ai suivi le
disque dur de Mikod notre sujet je sais
pas si
c'est bonjour à Micod
donc on a vu une ministre
son disque dur a disparu de sa tour.
Comment vous expliquez qu'on a des
ministres en France et qu'on a des
ministères où il y a des disques durs
qui disparaissent ? C'est grave ? C'est
pas grave ? Qu'est-ce que ça représente
comme danger ? Déjà, quand on a accès
physiquement à une bécane, est-ce que ça
représente une un ordinateur pardon ?
Est-ce que ça représente un danger ?
Comment ça se fait ? Qu'est-ce que ça
dit du fait qu'on arrive à sortir des
discurs de des ministères sans se faire
attraper ? Est-ce que vous avez des
petites idées là-dessus ? Est-ce que
c'est est-ce que vous êtes content de
l'investissement de nos impôts ?
Alors, on va peut-être pas se prononcer
directement sur les impôts.
Alors, le contrôle fiscal,
ça viendra peut-être en fin de
Non, par contre, effectivement, ça nous
permet de faire la jonction sur l'autre
composante de notre du métier qu'on
exerce aujourd'hui, c'est et la
réalisation de test d'intrusion
physique.
Comment elle s'appelle ta boîte déjà ?
BZ DUNT. Donc effectivement sur la sur
la partie de réalisation de test
d'intrusion physique aujourd'hui, on a
de plus en plus de boîtes qui qui ont
qui prennent cette conscience là euh sur
le fait que le période physique est très
souvent bah une extension ou la
fondation c'est ça
ouais
il est soit la fondation soit
l'extension en fait de leur de leur
périmètre virtuel de leur périmètre
cyber. Donc pour donc je vais je vais
essayer de répondre au type question que
que tu as posé pour bien m'aider
là-dessus. C'est un thème qui est
extrêmement vaste. Euh mais aujourd'hui
oui, un vecteur d'entrée physique
constitue un vecteur de risque cyber. Là
en l'occurrence pour l'exemple que tu
viens de citer concernant le vol d'un
disque dur euh par rapport à par rapport
à notre ami qu'on a évoqué précédemment
effectivement bah par rapport à la
donnée d'entreprise
et de des utilisateurs qui sont hébergés
sur cette solution cloud. euh un accès
physique à un téléphone, à à un poste
informatique, c'est une c'est un risque
de compromission clairement. Euh alors
sur le sur le le delta t qu'il faut pour
un attaquant que mais pour compromettre
un poste à partir du moment où il y a il
y a accès
les paramètres sont les les paramètres
environnementaux bien sûr viennent
viennent impacter là-dessus et
d'ailleurs c'est c'est de tr
tu branches tu branches une clé enfin tu
branches un de qui tu branches une
petite clé USB et puis ça reproduit les
touches clavier et ton chel il est
ouvert. même avec la solution antivirale
en place, même avec deed quand enfin on
reste sur un principe de force. De toute
manière quand on veut, on peut. Donc on
le
il y a des newb qui sont avec nous qui
nous écoutent. Il faut que tuexpliques
chell, il faut que tuexpliques tout ça.
D'accord. Euh donc ce dans le cadre d'un
scénario d'intrusion physique
effectivement si euh alors on n'est pas
sur le vol du disque dur mais euh j'ai
accès à un poste, je veux juste être de
passage sur un format 3 4 secondes et
effectivement je veux pouvoir par la
suite accéder à ce poste à distance
tranquillement au chaud sans m'exposer.
Euh c'est euh alors session si on
déverrouillé, on a d'autres scénarios
mais on branche une petite clé USB
sur le port USB et celle-ci en fait se
comporte comme un clavier. Euh donc déjà
en plus même s'il y a des petites règles
de sécurisation, pas de périphérique USB
externe, euh éventuellement on on
autorise que les claviers listés mais
généralement bah vu que c'est on connaît
les marques ou on connaît les commandes
donc en plus on peut même venir usurper
le petit vendor ID et se faire passer
pour un vrai périphérique. Mais en gros,
on le branche, ça saisit une touche de
enfin ça saisit une suite de de touche,
ça exécute des commandes sur la machine
et ça nous donne accès à distance via un
serveur.
Et tu passes la session Windows avec ça
?
Euh le login de session alors il y a
plusieurs scénarios. Si le poste est
déverrouillé, ça ça ouvre directement un
accès distance sur un serveur. Si la
machine est éteinte, il y a d'autres
clés où effectivement tu peux bipass le
loging Windows qui ne fonctionne pas
dans tous les cas parce que ça dépend si
le disque est bité, chiffré ou non. Ça
peut être aussi une autre solution de
chiffrement. eu des problèmes sur
bitlocur ? Non,
il y aura toujours des vol Si si tu
ressors les les toutes les vunes des des
solutions de de chiffre à l'époque, il y
a eu tout le scandale True Crypt aussi.
Je sais
crypt c'était magnifique. Vas-y reviens
reviens sur Tru Crypt. Moi
j'ai enfin je perdu en perinance
technique. Elle avait été bac d'or
c'était une update bac dorée je crois.
Enfin,
faut que tuexpliques avec des mots
comprensibles pour tout le monde.
Cit, c'était une mise à jour compromise
par des individus malicieux
qui avait mis implémenter des portes
dérobées.
Ouais,
c'est ça. Mais le dossier vu comment ça
les individus malicieux ? C'est un état.
Non, je crois bien.
Des individus
des individus
et bien équipés apparemment.
Ça ça a trois lettres. C'est ça. C'est
PT.
Non, mais avant c'est ceux qui font de
la PT, c'est la N S. Ah, c'est ça ?
On va appeler l'ambassade américaine
d'ailleurs. Euh, on va les faire venir
dans de dans 20 minutes, il n relance le
débat
Stocknet.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, direct.
Mais
par contre, ça ça allait vraiment un
débat qui est très intéressant qui est
celui de l'attribution. C'estàd que
aujourd'hui, comment est-ce qu'on
attribue une attaque cyber ? Déjà,
est-ce que la France le fait ? Alors
là-dessus, et je le reconnais
clairement, je suis loin d'être un
expert en à la matière. Par contre, il
me semble que l'attribution d'une
cyberattaque à une entité, à un état
nation, à un groupe criminel n'est pas
réellement faite aujourd'hui ou du moins
se communiquer de manière réellement
officielle dans les médias ou via les
canaux officiels par les par les
représentants ou les porte-paroles du
gouvernement.
Est-ce que ça se fait de manière
officieuse ? Possiblement. Certaines
personnes disent que des fichiers qui
ont été qui ont été fuités justement bah
démontrer des efforts de de
renseignement à ce sujet-là. Je ne
m'avance pas en tout cas sur cette
matière-là. Par contre, si on revient
dans le domaine public aujourd'hui des
des États comme les USA, comme la
Russie, comme la Chine, eux n'ont pas en
tout cas n'ont pas ce problème-là à à
faire ce qu'on appelle du name and
shame, donc vraiment pointer du doigt le
l'ennemi. Alors, pourquoi est-ce que
c'est compliqué de le faire et pourquoi
est-ce que bah en France c'est aussi
c'est aussi également difficile, c'est
que derrière remettre l'attribution d'un
d'un acte qui peut s'apparenter à un
acte de guerre aujourd'hui, c'est une
raison pour laquelle on appelle ça
aujourd'hui un acte de guerre numérique,
c'est quand même remettre une lourde
responsabilité diplomatique sur les
échanges qui peut y avoir dans d'autres
contextes qui sont non cyber. Ça peut
être remettre la la l'accès dans d'un
dans axe de guerre, ça peut être bloquer
des relations commerciales derrière à à
une échelle géopolitique.
Des exemples de ça déjà déjà fait. Par
exemple, quand il trafique les balises
GPS des bateaux, qu'il y a des bateaux
militaires qui se retrouvent dans des
eaux où il va pas être alors que sur
leur écrre, il y a marqué qu' a tout va
bien. L'Estonie en 2007. Non,
ça c'est la Russie qui attaqué
l'Estonie. Ça je crois ils ont pris très
cher, je crois. Ais parils avaient déjà
à l'époque une enfin pas une
hyperdépendance mais ils étaient hyper
numérique où euh il avait 70 % des
services public et privé qui passaient
par le net où ils avaient déjà le vote
le vote en ligne euh full full presse et
information par internet euh tous les
commandes de service et de facturation
enfin ils se retrouv en blackout le vote
en ligne vous en pensez quoi les
machines à vote. On a un excellent
exemple
de
euh
le programme qui est passé en public.
Et bien aujourd'hui donc le la Suisse et
alors il me semble que c'est donc c'est
porté par le par la poste.
Je dis pas de le Ouais, c'est le c'est
le Swiss Post à vérifier mais c'est
Swiss Post qui suisse qui a sorti le
programme de B sorti un programme de
Bugby public effectivement sur lequel on
a accès aujourd'hui à l'ensemble du code
source
de du système de vote public en Suisse.
Et aujourd'hui pour vous donner euh un
montant justement ben au niveau du bug
Bounty, c'est-à-dire que sur sur ces sur
ces primala faille là, certains
scénarios la le donc le le le l'entité
qui gère ce programme de bug buntil là
est prête à rémunérer jusqu'à il me
semble 230000 € une unique faille sur ce
système de de en tout cas de de vote.
C'estàd que il y a une réelle
attribution de moyens, une prise de
conscience de la nécessité d'impliquer
des chercheurs
du monde entier pour venir endurcir un
système
puis d'une certaine manière enfin je
pense c'est la pas du la pas du gain et
le montant des récompenses proposées
doit aussi faire se poser la question à
certains disant ça peut être wou enfin
ça peut être intéressant de de le faire
dans un contexte où c'est cadré tout est
prêt enfin c'est légal quoi. Ça peut
peut-être commencer à faire changer les
les esprits. Enfin, j'espère que ça a
une incidence à ce niveau.
Le plus gros bunt que vous avez chassé
vous deux, c'est combien ?
Euh, c'était sur une faille mais qui a
arrosé sur plusieurs G femmes, je peux
pas tous les donner. Et on est sur une
enveloppe à 100 à peu près, partagé à
deux. Ouais.
100 K.
Ouais.
OK. 100000, c'est bien. Vous payez des
impôts dessus ? Alors euh on paye Oui,
puisque il y a même trop de
déclarations, ça a été surdéclaré mais
oui oui les euh donc à l'époque c'était
en autoentreprise mais il y a eu donc
c'était il y avait plus d'ACR euh la il
y avait le paiement de la TVA euh après
bah toutes toutes les joys un peu sur le
revenu les cotisations. Ouais ouais. Bon
de toute façon c'est pas nous qui gérant
c'est le comptable voilà
et d'ailleurs
non vraiment pour la toute petite
anecdote c'est sur l'aspect
communautaire et partage du hacking
aujourd'hui il y a quelqu'un dans la
communauté française il me semble que
c'est Norage si je dis pas de bêtises
qui en fait a créé un un repos guitup
donc sur lequel on gèrement on met du
code source ou la documentation et qui a
documenté vraiment tous les tutoriels
nécessaires à la pratique de l'activité
du bug bountti et par rapport à la
complexité des des systèmes de de
paiement des impôts
parce en fait La communauté, tu as
vraiment tout types de profil et l'idée
c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut arriver
aussi en tant que communauté ? Oui,
c'est étonnant. comment la communauté
peut contribuer à ce que ce soit
accessible à tout le monde et dans cet
esprit de partage qui est une valeur
fondatrice enfin fondamentale du de
l'esprit du ha quoi.
Donc il y a des tutos pour les impôts.
Il y a des tutos pour les impôts. Tu
veux faire du bug bounti, tu ouvres ton
compte auto-entreprise. Ta déclaration
de TVA, tu l' fais dès que tu dépasses
le plafond temps. Euh tu peux choisir
retenu à la source ou prélèvement. Enfin
bref, tu as tout le tuto de A à Z avec
les petits screenshots, enfin avec les
petit pourquoi il a dû faire ça ? Parce
qu'il y avait bon nombre qui faisait pas
de déclaration d'impôts et ensuite Beril
les utilisait en disant "Tu vas venir
travailler parce que tu as pas bien fait
tes impôts". Après, on je il y a eu je
pense peut-être des abus mais dans
l'idée avec enfin je pense que l'état
d'esprit de la commue comme pour la
technique c'est il y a une problématique
c'est pas grave on prend le taureau par
les cornes et on trouve des solutions.
Donc ceux qui veulent s'y mettre demain
le tuto est là vous pouvez utiliser.
C'est libre, c'est gratuit, c'est dans
l'esprit de partage.
Revenons, revenons sur les machines à
vote.
Ouais.
Et vous votez vous, vous êtes pas obligé
de répondre.
Moi, je veux pas répondre.
D'accord. Victoire.
Alors ben on va on va faire non, je suis
transparent là-dessus. J'ai 24 ans. Les
dernières élections auxquelles je
j'étais en âge de voter, j'avais 18 ans.
À l'époque, je passais mes concours,
j'ai pas eu le temps de m'inscrire sur
les sur la liste électorale. Donc pour
les présidentiels, non, j'ai pas eu le
temps de de voter. Et pour les c en tout
cas à l'échelle inférieure, donc tout ce
qui est régional, départemental,
communal, j'avoue que j'étais plus pris
par l'aspect boulot et à l'époque. Donc
non, j'ai pas voté. Est-ce que ça vous
fait peur que notre système démocratique
se retrouve euh au milieu d'un océan de
vulnérabilité ? Et est-ce que vous
pensez que nos dirigeants en ont
réellement pris conscience ?
Euh fou. Alors
Victor, tu voulais parler ou pas ? Non
Victor, tu veux commencer ? Non non là
c'est la question qui est qui est
intéressante. Ce sera pas forcément
vulnérabilité parce que si tu reprends
du Cambridge Analytica,
ouais turf qui va bien,
est-ce que finalement tu es vraiment sur
une vulnérabilité technique ? Euh
non maisant je te parle sur les
machines, on verra sur l'antériorité de
la mise en considération en mise en
préparer sa population à voter dans le
bon sens. On en si tu veux, on peut en
reparler mais sur la sur l'aspect
technique, tu te retrouves face à une
bécane que tu connais pas qui est pas
auditable. En France, le code il a le
code source n'est pas publié. Si si on
passe largement là-dessus, il faudra que
le code source des machines à vot soit
publié. Mais est-ce que ça te fait peur
les machines à vot ? Est-ce que est-ce
que le le bulletin dans l'urne à
l'ancienne, c'est pas mieux ? Est-ce que
le dra technologique démocratique qu'est
le bulletin de vote, c'est peut-être pas
mieux ? C'est quoi le d technologique ?
On vire tout ce qui est écran et carte
mère,
tout ce qui se branche sur le secteur.
Bah le j'ai pas de vis enfin je j'ai je
pas la connaissance de est-ce que ça a
été audité, testé ou autre. Je sais pas
com pour toi. Est-ce que ça te fait peur
?
Vu que je sais pas et que je me suis pas
renseigné
mais avec ton background technique tu
Ah bah il y aura toujours si il y aura
toujours la faille. Si je enfin si tu
veux trouver la faille, tu la trouveras.
Ça c'est enfin il y a rare enfin on on a
jamais eu la situation où tu trouves
rien.
Tu trouves toujours ?
Tu trouves toujours effectivement pas
avec les mêmes niveaux d'impact. Si tu
as le temps, l'argent, tu trouves
toujours.
Bah c'est exactement ça. Sur des projets
de RD où on sait qu'il y a quelque chose
à aller chercher mais qu'on a pas 6 mois
à allouer, bah effectivement, on fait
pas la mise en évidence, on fait pas la
mise en en évidence technique, mais on
sait que la faille est là, mais il va
falloir effectivement du temps, des
ressources et encore on le fait sans
argent quoi. Enfin, on fait sans argent,
c'est juste on produit rien. Et si on en
plus tu avais 15 gars à disposition
enfin sur le budget de la
cybercriminalité, il est il est
colossal.
Effectivement, c'est pas le même rapport
de force non plus.
Victor, tu veux rajouter un mot ?
Oui, l'autre problématique c'est
aujourd'hui même si on a des applicatifs
qui peuvent être audités, qui peuvent
être en tout cas open source sur lequel
aujourd'hui on on a enfin dans un monde
idéal, on pourrait avoir la communauté
qui pourrait porter un regard critique
dessus. Donc quand je dis communauté
aussi bien des spécialistes de la
cybersécurité que des informaticiens
standard, des admin systèmes, peu
importe, que des mathématiciens ou des
cryptologues. Très bien, c'est
intéressant. Par contre derrière euh on
a toujours le le problème de la paranoï
qui est en fait rien ne nous assure que
le système qui tourne effectivement sur
la machine soit le même que celui qui a
été qui a été derrière. Donc
effectivement quand on commence à se
prancher sur les problématiques cyber,
on devient très vite paranoïque. Et de
mon côté en tout cas, je suis n'est-ce
pas paranoïque ? Ça c'est encore un mot
qu'on t'a mis dans la tête.
C'est vrai. C'est vrai.
Tu es vigilant.
Ah très vigilant du coup. Non. Et
effectivement par contre à titre
personnel, oui, c'est quelque chose qui
en tout cas qui me fait peur par rapport
aux problématiques sécuritaires. Par
contre, si on si la la
crainte sousjacante est celle d'une
manipulation des votes,
aujourd'hui, ça a déjà enfin
ça déjà
ça alors je vais pas je je je n'évoque
pas la partie fraude sur de la partie
cyber par contre sur des sur des
gouvernements territoriaux euh qui
peuvent utiliser le bulletin de vote
tout à fait standard sur laquelle pour
caricaturer on peut se retrouver à 120 %
de vote pour un candidat
la manipulation elle peut être faite que
que l'on s'attaque à l'humain ou que
l'on s'attaque à une machine. Donc pour
moi, ça permet aussi de remettre en
perspective peut-être un petit peu un
petit peu ce niveau de menace là.
Est-ce que vous avez lu le rapport sur
la Chine
650 pages sorties par l'incerne.
Je vous le conseille.
C'est petit caviar. C'est petit caviar
Nutella.
Revenons. Revenons à notre question. Tu
parlais de la communauté.
Est-ce que la communauté doit la
communauté française Oui.
de Haking doit faire fond par rapport
aux menaces géopolitique
que la France est amenée à faire face du
moins à affronter ? Est-ce que il faut
faire passer le message dans la
communauté que en face de nous, il y a
les Chinois
qui ont un état d'esprit
nationaliste, patriote, appelez ça comme
vous voulez, vénère. Il y a les
Nord-Coréens, il y a les Russes, il y a
surtout les Américains. Est-ce que nous
les Français comme on voit le K d'orsa
partir un peu en sucette que LAN a
commencé à faire son boulot correctement
que puis Guillaume
est arrivé ? Est-ce qu'il faut faire
passer le message de protéger le pays
par tous les moyens ?
Alors par tous les moyens, ça va très
loin.
Ouais, j'ai une anecdote à suiv. On
était au fic il y a 15 jours.
Bon, de manière un peu
rien de privé au fic, pas de backstage,
rien du tout. OK.
Non non non non, t'inquiète. Et de
manière un peu désinvolte, on a été posé
la question de la légalité du hackback
en disant
frapper en retour.
Frapper en retour. Aujourd'hui, tuas une
enfin tu as une nébuleuse où bah je suis
particulier, je suis professionnel, je
me fais attaquer. Est-ce que au même
titre que la légitime défense de je me
fais agresser dans la rue, j'ai le droit
de répondre ? Euh concrètement
oui et non, on a pas le droit
concrètement non. Tu as pas enfin en
tant que particulier, tu as pas le droit
de répondre ou en tant que
professionnel, tu n'as pas le droit de
répondre. Mais c'était de savoir si euh
nos enfin nos nos autorités euh
compétentes, nos corps d'armée avaient
on n'a pas eu la réponse. On a essayé de
l'avir mais on a gratté mais on nous a
rien lâché.
Tu
étais au fic aussi, tu as vu ça ?
Ah oui oui, j'étais là, j'étais moins.
On on était
Alors le fic le fic le fic c'est forum
international de la cybersécurité.
C'était c'est à Lille tous les ans.
Ça il y a pas trop de flic cette année ?
Ah si, tu as toujours tu as toujours une
une grande présence des des corps
d'armée euh de la police nationale,
enfin de tous les corps de de de ces
secteurs-ci et parce que qui plus est
recrutent enfin il y a un nombre de
postes ouverts incalculables et la
question initiale,
c'est une excellente question.
Est-ce qu'il y en avait pas trop ?
Est-ce qu'on doit faire passer le
message que il faut qu'on serre les
coudes même si nos institutions popbuci
? Est-ce que nous de notre côté on est
plus résilient, on est plus agile ?
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on prenne en main
la défense du pays ? Alors, et par
contre là-dessus justement par rapport
au comparatif, oui, très bien. Donc, on
a des ennemis qui sont extrêmement
patriotiques, qui sont extrêmement
nationalistes. Euh aujourd'hui, je je
pense donc sans partir sur le débat
polétique que la plupart des en tout cas
des des hackers euh ont euh ont ont
conscience de l'enjeu cyber et on ont
quand même l'amour de la patrie. Et donc
cette sensibilité pour moi, elle
s'exprime au quotidien, pas sur les
sujets de défense étant que en fait on
est incapable de s'en approcher en tant
que en tant que indépendant. C'est ça.
Par contre pour moi, elle s'exprime au
quotidien sur le travail qui est fait
euh probono vis-à-vis de d'action, enfin
vis-à-vis des entreprises, vis-à-vis euh
d'ONG, vis-à-vis des des citoyens que
que l'on peut aider. Donc pour moi, la
communauté oui a cette a cet amour de la
patrie, à son l'amour de son prochain,
si je peux cacer de cette manière-là.
Euh est-ce que on devrait mettre à
disposition les ressour enfin est-ce
qu'on devrait fédérer les ressources
qu'on a de la communauté
pour les stapper un peu ?
En fait, c'est vrai que tu vois, c'est
c'est jamais ça qui est ressorti. C'est
plus le Oui. l'entraide citoyenne, le
bénévola et le probono quand on mène ce
genre d'action. Euh ça a été le dossier
avait été initié historiquement par
Yogacha là-dessus qui est l'une des
plateformes de On dit bonjour à Yassir.
Salut Yassir, je suis sûr que tu
écoutes.
Qui est l'une des plateformes de Bugby
Buunty française euh
avec Yesak
avec Yesak également. Bonjour à Freeman
et et vas-y contin
et tu vois dans ces moments-ci la
communauté avait été réunie pour bah
typiquement début Covid et c'était déjà
ils avaient fait donc c'est le programme
Act for Values que ça s'appelle
euh ça avait été fait pour médecin sans
frontière Saféra
fait un beau logo avec des cœurs. C'est
ça. Médecin sans frontière. Euh début
Covid, on avait avec lancé le sujet des
hôpitaux qui prenaient mais alors tarif
euh avec le le début de vous avez après
le vous avez 10 jours pour vous mettre
tous en télétravail où tu as eu
recrudescence fishing, le laise et on va
cibler, on va targetter les hôpitaux qui
sont sous l'eau et qui ont d'autres
problématiques que l'informatique et la
séc. Donc là, on avait proposé en
probono effectivement de faire du bugti
sans gratification, juste fédérer la
commune, prendre 30 gars et puis on va
aller sur sur un un lapse de temps
court, trouver un max de faille, leur
faire les préca de comment on corrige,
les impacts et essayer de faire avancer
quoi.
Vous avez bien évacué ma question les
gars, c'était pas mal fait. Non, mais
c'est c'était pour dire que c'est ça en
fait qu'on met en avant plus que
l'aspect on fédère euh on fédère sur un
sujet plus effectivement cyberguerre
géopolitique et autres. Est-ce que là à
l'heure actuelle, il y a un peu une
étanchéité entre la commue alors à
laquelle on appartient, mais ça veut pas
dire que ça représente tout le monde et
finalement nos autorités compétentes en
France, le ministère des armées. Euh
enfin, tu vois, c'est voilà, c'est
là-dessus, tu as effectivement on est
c'est c'est de monde à part d'une
certaine manière et on se concentre du
coup plus sur des engagements citoyens
et tu regardes au fic Yasuyak l' refait
encore avec la Croix-Rouge où c'était
filé un coup de main à la Croix-Rouge et
c'était Yesuak qui payait quoi. C'est
très bien. Il est qu'ils ont un grand
cœur. Victor, tu veux rajouter quelque
chose ?
Oui. Non, mais même alors allons dans
cette continuité là. Donc, mettons que
demain très bien euh toute la communauté
du pays soit fédérée
vis-à-vis des actions de cyberger. Par
contre, concrètement, ça se fait comment
?
Et surtout pas se tromper de la R Post.
Alors, la problématique de
l'attribution, on l' évoqué tout à
l'heure. Donc, déjà, est-ce qu'on est
sûr de taper sur la bonne personne ?
Premier point. Second point, c'est
comment est-ce qu'on engage des civils
dans une opération de alors c'est plus
que d'aller à la défense nationale mais
en tout cas dans une opération armée.
Tu prends l'exemple des Russes qui va
pouvoir faire les réserves
réserves après. Comment est-ce que
comment est-ce que tu en regardes ces
personnesl ? Ensuite, si tu considères
que ces personnesl, elles ont elles ont
elles ont un haut potentiel, d'accord,
que ce sont des personnes avec un
savoir-faire qui est rare, un
savoirfaire technique et spécifique,
donc des cibles de haute valeur. Comment
est-ce que tu embrigades des civils dans
une guerre qui potentiellement peut les
mettre en danger et qui potentiellement
également peut mettre la notion en
danger au vi de un de leurs accès, deux
de leurs connaissances techniques
spécifiques et donc trois de la façon
dont dont ils vont dont ils vont opérer.
C'est bon, je t'engage toi, je t'engage
tout de suite. Par contre, c'est vrai
qu'en terme de stratégie militaire, ça
va être un tout autre sujet si euh le
conflit de demain à l'échelle mondiale,
c'est euh c'est euh cyber, quoi.
Et donc
ça et en fait, ça nous amène sur les
deux prochains points qui sont euh de un
comment est-ce que tu cadres un milieu
qui est basé sur la liberté de pensée et
la liberté d'action. Donc là-dessus,
c'est une problématique de management
qui est inhérente entre guillemets à ce
cœur d'activité et qui touchera aussi
bien à l'armée que les entreprises que
les entreprises privées.
Tu nous vois militaire ?
Bah j'ai l'amour de la patrie. Mais
ouais, c'est ça. C'est le cadrage qui va
être affreux quoi.
Comment est-ce qu'on rentre dans ce
cadre là ? Je je c'est incompatible
aujourd'hui avec la façon de travailler
qu' a une majeure partie de personnes
dans dans la communauté parce que
c'est un gros problème ça même dans les
boîtes. Ou
ouais. Comment on fait pour engager des
hackeurs ? On fait on si on monter un
pôle cybersécurité dans une boîte, on
fait quoi ? On prend un appartement au
dernier étage avec une grande terrasse
pour faire les barbecue, si possible à
moins de 5 minutes du du lieu de
travail, du du lieu d'habitation et si
possible avec des pièces pour faire la
sieste et si possible avec des stock
option ou des bons souscription d'action
pour fidéliser son PC,
travailler de sujet.
Vous voulez rajouter des petites
conditions de travail en plus ? Il y
avait la bande d'arquad qui nous tenait
à cœur et si pas de CV le challenge
technique à résoudre pour postuler.
Pas de CV obligatoire ça.
Des compétences rédactionnelles quand
même. Mais ça c'est comme le reste si tu
sais pas bah tu apprends ou et voilà.
Victor
non ça et puis derrière c'est en fait
trouver la alors c'est c'est une petite
digression mais c'est trouver la la zone
enfin quand dans dans tous les secteurs
d'activité je pense quand on est assez
passionné par par un sujet par un
exercice que soit technique mental peu
importe on a on on est le plus efficient
dans une dans ce qu'on appelle le la
zone c'est vraiment une une
sorte de moment de grâce où on a notre
concentration qui est optimale parce que
toutes les variables environnementales
sont parfaites. On est dans un élément
qu'on connaît dans un dans un lieu qui
est qu'on considère comme étant
confortable, dans des meilleures
conditions pour travailler. Et
aujourd'hui, étant donné que la plupart
des en tout cas des personnes de de la
communauté ont fait ça bah toute seule
chez elle gèmement dans leur coin, pour
nous c'est aussi important que bah
potentiellement les personnes qui
peuvent nous rejoindre puissent se
reconstituer cette bulle dans laquelle
bah on est capable de donner le meilleur
de nos compétences et pas simplement
pour un aspect business parce que
simplement pour un aspect de bien-être.
parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça
fait c'est vraiment une partie inhérente
de la manière dont on travaille. Il faut
qu'on soit capable de se plonger et de
se concentrer tout en ayant cette
liberté de de penser et d'action.
La seule problématique qu'on a, c'est
qu'on mange toi
[__] J'étais très corporate avant
mais ça c'était avant.
Rigole pas toi.
Tu veux rajouter un beau bruit sur la
réserve ?
Bah la réserve non parce que c'est
Victor qui a le plus bosser le sujet.
Alors donc on va on va revenir on va
revenir sur sur l'aspect engagement
citoyen. Très bien. Donc aujourd'hui euh
on est à cœur éthique. Euh on fait on
réalise des remontées de vulnérabilité.
Donc quand on peut de dans le cadre
d'action citoyenne, on aide euh notre
prochain, on aide une entreprise, peu
importe. Euh OK, très bien. Mais
maintenant bah on a vu le on a vu le
contexte cyber, on a vu la résistance
des cyberattaques qui peuvent nous
cibler, qui peuvent cibler d'autres
états, qui qui soient considérés comme
étant alliés, comme ennemi, peu importe.
C'est comment est-ce que moi je mets mes
compétences aujourd'hui au service de la
nation, même si bah aujourd'hui voilà,
j'ai la j'ai la visé j'ai la vision
entrepreneuriale, mais comment est-ce
qu'on peut comment est-ce qu'on peut
aider ? Comment est-ce que voilà, on il
y a on a des bras, comment est-ce qu'on
peut y ses bras ?
On a posé la question mais ça c'est pas
bien fini quoi.
Voilà. Alors euh en 2019 9 2019 ou 2020
euh la la réserve cyberdéfense donc
comme toutes les réserves en tout cas la
majeure partie des réserves est divisée
entre une réserve citoyenne et une
réserve active. Euh la réserve active il
me semble implique des engagements de
disponibilité sur des sur des sur des
missions dans que la réserve citoyenne
elle n'est pas soumise à ces engagements
là. Donc effectivement quand on a une
vision entrepreneuriale, on n'est pas
forcément à même de pouvoir se rendre
disponible sur un créneau, un delta t de
façon assurée. Par contre, bah si on a
quand même envie d'aider, qu'est-ce qui
reste ? Il reste la réserve citoyenne.
Donc 2019-2020, on est j'avais fait les
procédés à l'époque pour rejoindre pour
rejoindre la réserve citoyenne. On
m'avait dit bah c'est cool monsieur mais
par contre en fait non, on est plein
donc il y a il reste que des places pour
l'active. Pas de souci. Très bien, bonne
journée, au revoir. Et là donc
effectivement cette année au fic euh on
a on est on est revenu amener le sujet
sur sur la table. On a l'occasion
d'échanger donc avec des avec du
personnel de de l'armée. Bonjour. Voilà.
Voilà ce qu'on fait. Voilà ce qu'on sait
faire. Voilà notre cœur de métier et
c'est là qu'on sera utile.
On n pas le temps de faire de l'active.
Par contre on peut faire de la
citoyenne. Oui, pas de souci. Les places
sont réouvertes. Je je c'est c'est
extra. Voici les Voici le petit Voici le
petit flyer et puis voilà, vous envoyez
un petit mail. CV lettes de motivation
bien sûr
forcément
et puis on vous attribuera une mission
qui vous ira bien mais plus
vous avez l'air jeunes quand même dans
les écoles ça irait bien quoi.
Voilà. Ouais vous vous avez jeunes l'air
sympa les jeunes vont vous adorer.
Ça fait
qui voulait te faire faire du baby
sitting de de de sensibilisation. C'est
vrai
le terme ambassadeur.
Pas mal pas mal.
Ambassadeur jeune
c'était ambassadeur et sensibilisation.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Mais il y a le problème c'est que c'est
décor Attends, attends attends
attendsends attends. Je coup, c'est un
scandale.
Je je peux confier juste un petit bout
sans sans sans rentrer dans les tails.
On a bossé ensemble cet été sur un
dossier.
La réponse qu'on t'a donné, c'est un
scandale parce que tu es quand même une
brute.
Ça après c'est alors ça c'est c'est la
commun c'est les c'est c'est les tiers
qui doivent le dire. Enfin, pour moi,
pour moi, le terme à cœur, c'est pas
quel enfin, c'est comme le terme
d'expert, on n'est pas censé se la poser
sur lui-même. C'est ce sont les tiers
qui doivent qui doivent la poser.
On te reconnaît comme ça.
Bah, en tout cas, merci.
Non, je vais pas dire que vous boulot
tous les deux, même si on a rien trouvé,
on a trouvé quand même.
On a trouvé quand même.
Question internet.
compte tenu de l'évolution vers la
cyberguerre et de l'essence même de la
culture à cœur, où se situeraient les
intervenants en cas de conflit à
l'échelle nationale ou mondiale ?
Alors même si enfin on va répondre
chacun
même si euh il serait très difficile de
me gérer sur le plan militaire enfin je
enfin je je m'engagerai ou je défendrai
mon pays il y a pas de souci.
Mais je rejoins entièrement br là-dessus
et c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure c'est euh on a des
compétences quelle est la place d'un
individu qui a des compétences
spécifiques techniques dans la société
et quelle est la place de ce même
individu dans un environnement de garde
et où est-ce qu'il est le plus utile ?
OK, très bien. Bah alors, je j'ai fait
du tir sportif, j'apprécie ça. Mais
est-ce que je serais plus utile en
première ligne ou est-ce que je serais
plus utile derrière un clavier ?
Aujourd'hui, la réponse c'est c'est la
dernière. C'est
même nos corps armés le découvrent
encore enfin le découvrent et et
construisent les nouvelles stratégies
militaires au quotidien quoi.
Autre question internet, des idées pour
aider le système de santé face aux
cyberattaques.
Oh [__] ! Alors, il est quelle heure ?
trop long parce qu'on doit avoir des
libéral.
Vas-y, continue.
Alors, il y a un contexte historique à à
faer parce que dans la santé, j'avais
commencé euh j'étais au chômage,
j'allais commencé en faisant vraiment.
Tu étais pas au chômage, tu étais en
recherche.
Ah oui, c'est vrai. [__] j'ai oublié.
J'étais en recherche de et
questionnement.
Je faisais le tour des officines à
l'époque sur le fini. Attends,
les officines de quoi ?
Officines les officines, c'est
pharmacies.
D'accord.
Donc je faisais le tour à l'époque en en
tant que juste passionné pour dire
bonjour, vous avez telle problématique
sécuritaire, on a accès à toute la
donnée patient. Votre prestat en fait,
on s'est rendu compte qu'il a arrosé
enfin je donnerai pas la zone
géographique mais on était sur une
région complète. Vous avez les mêmes mot
de passes que les voisins là-bas.
Appelez le prestat et demandz à ce queil
viennent corriger les conneries qu'il a
fait quoi. Ça commencé comme ça il y a
encore un an. C'était euh tu vois les
hôpitaux publics avec le service de
transport le service de transport
accessible ouvert sur le net et encore
en ce moment même sans pouvoir donner
plus de détails, on est sur
Attends, on donne pas de vulnérab. OK,
continue.
T'inquiète pas. Bon, on est on est
habitué aux engagements de confier. On
est sur un incident où il va falloir
remobiliser. Maintenant, on a un cert en
France santé. T'explique ce que c'est un
set.
Donc un set c'est un
emergency. J'ai les trois derniers
response team et le emergency response
team et l'autre c'est center.
C'est un centre de réponse en tout cas
qui fait de la veille de vulnérabilité
et qui
qui surveille qui a à l'écoute des
remontées pour derrière coordonner. Bah
typiquement quand ça touche plusieurs
établissements d'un coup ou un GHT le
groupement les groupements hospitaliers
du territoire là derrière tu es sur des
usines à gaz parce que donc le médical
ça a évolué dans un bazar monstre. Il y
a eu de l'HDS qui était des
explique à chaque fois hein
exigences sécuritaires sur des
hébergeurs de données de santé. Il y a
eu des spécificités, on leur a dit à un
moment c'est donc c'est Elan qui
intervient mais il y a aussi l'ARS Santé
qui porte c'est l'agence
nationale de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information donc c'est l'une des
autorités de régulation en France et qui
fait le chef d'orchestre
et à un moment il y a enfin et il y a
également la RS santé la RS santé du
coup l'agence régionale de la santé qui
traite prend aussi une petite brique de
la cyber
il y a eu les programmes hôpitaux
numérique
euh ça part dans un tumulte fou mais
dans tous les cas c'est une vraie
volonté de mise en conformité des
hôpitaux publics sauf qu'on reste sur
des problématiques de fond où on prend
le CH le CHU dans le coin où on est. Euh
si tu reprends les six dernières années,
le le RSSI, donc le responsable de la
sécurité du système d'information, il
arrive, il tient 10-moi, il part parce
qu'il dit j'ai pas de budget. Est-ce
qu'il dit euh euh il y a 20 cas sur la
table ? Effectivement, ça va servir au
nouveau chir qui arrive avec son TP Link
euh web parce qu'il veut brancher son
MacBook dans son bureau et que il a dit
"fuck", je ne respecterai pas les
engagements. Il y a tout le bazar côté
biomède. Le biomède, c'est une
catastrophe. C'est tous les équipements
aujourd'hui ça coûte des millions
d'euros sur lesquels il y a pas eu
d'exigences sécuritaires sur le plan
contractuel et tu te retrouves avec du
Windows XP sur une machine à IRM.
Magnifique.
Enfin voilà donc tu prends tout ce bazar
là et c'est qui plus S n'est pas leur
métier en fait. Ces gens-là sont faits
pour soigner. Il y a aussi des
contraintes fortes. Demander à une
infirmière dans un service des urgences
de verrouiller son poste et de retaper
son mot de passe à chaque fois qu'elle a
besoin d'accéder à un dossier patient.
Tu vois, il y a une il y a il y a un
secteur d'activité qui est tellement
spécifique où à travers les GHT aussi,
on leur a dit mutualiser les ressources
et les infrastructure pas qu'umaine mais
aussi informatique, essayer
d'uniformiser. Mais est-ce que
finalement la bonne solution c'était pas
aussi d'une certaine manière de dire ce
que vous ne savez pas faire,
externalisez-le et donnez-le à des à des
entités qui sont spécialisées sur ce
traitement. Vous pouvez pas faire, enfin
on le voit hein, quand on quand on n'
pas l'occasion de faire que notre
travail quotidien et qu'on est parasité
par le reste, les joyeusés administratif
qu'on déteste, euh les suivis de projet
sur lesquels on fait un effort mais on
aime pas et qu'on n'est pas dans le cœur
pur de la tech, on se disperse et on
fait mal les choses. C'est un peu la
même chose quoi. les les milieu de la
santé et du médical. J'ai enfin je suis
même je dirais assez pessimiste
aujourd'hui puisque j'ai j'ai baisser
les bras et mis à part les actions
probo.
On fait les remontées quand on trouve
des failles. Est-ce que c'est une petite
goutte dans l'océan ou est-ce que
vraiment ce qu'on
continuer de le faire
et ce qu'on essaie de faire ça va
vraiment dérouler. continuer de le
faire,
mais il leur faut des budgets aussi, il
leur faut des ressources et euh et quand
tu échanges avec les RSSI, donc les
responsables de sécurité des des
systèmes d'information des hôpitaux
publics, on est content au moins de voir
certains aujourd'hui qui portent euh qui
sont moteurs et qui s'accrochent quoi.
Et mais c'est lourd et il a fallu des
années. Victor
je je suis entièrement briste là-dessus
et il avait il avait porté la démarche
bien avant que je rentre allemand dans
la cyber. J'étais dans le milieu santé
donc j'ai j'ai cette appétence là et je
le rejoins entièrement. Et
autre question internet. Le hacking
demande-t-il un développement de code ou
juste de l'utilisation d'outils info
existants
shark et des choses comme ça ? Alors, on
peut répondre de manière encore plus
minimaliste aujourd'hui. Euh le enfin le
hacking au sens large, c'est tu fais tu
trouves un un problème, tu le résous de
manière élégante en sortant outside
ofide the box, donc de la boîte. Par
contre, effectivement, si tu souhaites
l'appliquer aujourd'hui à l'IT, euh des
outils, il y en a énormément. Euh mais
d'ailleurs, est-ce qu'on est obligé de
l'utiliser ? Non, on peut créer nos
propres outils. Euh la l'outil le plus
important aujourd'hui, c'est ton état
d'esprit. Ça va être la manière de de
penser et de t'approprier ce qui a été
créé par la communauté. Une fois que tu
t'es approprié tout cela, derrière bah
soit tu utilises tes propres outils,
soit simplement bah tu utilises ce qui
est déjà existant pour ne pas réinventer
la roue.
Le BF, c'est quand tu es fignant quoi,
que tu veux pas refaire deux fois la
même chose.
C'est ça.
J'utiliser l'assembleur un peu ou des
choses comme ça.
J'ai
non parce qu'il faudrait 40 ans pour se
spécialiser. Assembleur aujourd'hui, on
l'a sur de la création de malware dans
des campagnes de fishing ciblé pour
avoir des trucs.
Tu connais les russes comme ça hein. Tu
as toujours des enfin en reverse on
n'est pas ultra spécialisé parce que
quand tu prends les mec explique ce que
c'est reverse,
non ? Euh aujourd'hui on fait donc de l'
de la mémonique d'assemblage parce qu'
l'assembleur c'est un abus de langage.
On fait de la mémonique d'assemblage
pour faire des bouts de codes malicieux
lorsqu'on fait par exemple des
entraînements de campagne de fishing
ciblé. C'est le seul endroit où on
intervient. C'est rien du tout par
rapport au large domaine qui est le
reverse engineering, donc la
rétroingénierie, ingénierie inversée qui
consiste à prendre un soft, un logiciel,
une souche virale et derrière venir euh
l'investiguer sur son fonctionnement. En
l'occurrence, c'est ce qu' essayent de
faire les éditeurs antivirux ou les
grands noms du domaine lorsqu'il y a un
nouveau un nouveau rançon logiciel qui
sort et qu'ils essayent retrouver la clé
de déchiffrement pour la mettre à
disposition des des victimes. Euh c'est
utilisé aussi dans des contextes
purement gaming où quand on fait des
sessions de des événements de Capture
the Flag où on est tous regroupés avec
la communauté et il y a des points à les
chercher en craquant des petits
applicatifs ou des trucs comme ça. Là,
on en fait un petit peu mais on a notre
niveau est très limité par rapport à
vraiment ce que font les enfin notamment
chez chez Casperski, c'est des taré
là-dessus.
C'est pas des tarés
mais c'est un compliment. C'est
on les connaît bien les gars de chez
Casperci. On s'est pris une racasse avec
eux. Ils sont super sympas.
Euh question internet.
Euh quel si alors il y a il y aura des
questions novice ? Il y aura des
questions monovis. D'accord. Quel
système d'exploitation outil
utilisent-il au quotidien, que ce soit
sur smartphone ou PC ? Ont-ils des
conseils à donner aux gens pour
améliorer leur sécurité dans la vie de
tous les jours ?
Alors, sur ce qu'on utilise à titre
personnel, le bon outil pour la bonne
serrure.
Donc
ça c'est full corpo comme réponse.
Bon,
d'accord.
Et ça peut être très tendancieux aussi.
Alors, je j'ai je vais redescendre d'un
tour. Du coup,
quand il faut du Windows, on utilise du
Windows. Quand il faut du Linux, on
utilise du Linux.
Majoritairement, c'est du Linux.
Majoritairement, c'est du Linux. Et il y
a aussi le côté bon, on a grandit avec,
on aime beaucoup ça. Je pense que je
peux dire qu'on préfère ça aussi.
Euh par contre, par rapport à par
rapport à un isateur standard
lambda.
Ouais, voilà. Ça par rapport à
initiateur lambda, c'est pas tant ça
aller s patouiller les mains avec
vraiment de la complicité technique.
C'est
les mises à jour en priorité,
c'est ça
un antivirus de qualité, nettoyer
régulièrement son navigateur.
C'est l'hygiène numérique en fait
de passe. Ouais. Lancy a mis un guide
gratuit sur son site, sur les règles
d'hygiène numérique et ça fait partie
des actions qui permettent justement de
vulgariser le sujet et de commencer à
sensibiliser le tout. C'est-à-dire que
c'est très accessible, c'est plus
vulgarisé que les non efforts que bon
que j'ai beaucoup fait ce soir sur le
discours technique. C'est vraiment des
cas d'usage simples au quotidien sur
l'aspect mot de passe, sur l'aspect
justement mise à jour. Ils ont créé des
référentiels qui sont sur leur site.
C'est téléchargeable, c'est consultable.
Après en terme de maintenance quand même
l'anecdote de tu installes buntu dans
toute la famille pour éviter de te
retaper des installes tous les ans et tu
as plus d'emmerde avec les mises à jour
renouveler les licences. Ça marche pas
trop mal aussi.
Euh, voyons voir. Est-ce qu'on a du gnou
dans les questions ? Pas encore. Et
question internet. Est-ce qu'il pense
que le gouvernement s'améliore en terme
de cybersécurité ? Fausem 2019, la
conférence Matrique in the French State
?
Alors, la référence, on ne l'a pas.
J'ai pas la référence.
Par contre, ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui, c'est que sur la c'est une
partie qui fait publiquement, c'est que
il y a des démarches en tout cas qui
sont initiées par le gouvernement pour
faire aujourd'hui appel à la à la
communauté. C'estàd que des programmes
de bug buun donc qui font appel à la
communauté de hacker ell eux en tout cas
sont ouverts donc sur cette partie là du
pmè
le perm cyber c'est extrêmement large.
C'est devenu un terme fourtout
cybersécurité aujourd'hui. Tu tu
déclines. Ça a été trop enfin ça a été
trop médiatité. C'est ça.
Ouais aussi.
Question internet. Une cyberattaque qui
conduirait à un déclochement du feu
nucléaire c'est possible ou pas ? Alors,
est-ce qu'on est dans le système qui
permet de dire oui ? Non, c'est pas
possible.
Moi, je peux te dire oui direct.
Bah sur
si tu as pas un commandant de bateau qui
est suffisamment stable dans sa tête, il
se retrouve dans les eaux territoriales
où il devrait pas y s'y retrouver. Si en
face tu as une marine avec un mec un peu
moins stable que l'autre qui est en
face, il se tape dessus, hein. La
réponse c'était plus par rapport à
vraiment à l'expot technique de est-ce
que très bien on peut contourner le fait
de mettre une de mettre une clé par
exemple.
Là-dessus, bah on peut pas répondre de
manière factuelle. Stocknet, c'est un
super qui a des colit de des campagnes
de ils ont droppé de l'USB autour de la
autour de la centrale. C'était pas ciblé
et du coup c'était un effet par rebond
où tu te dis tu viens arroser enfin
c'est finalement un peu en mode cheval
de 3
la clé USB Louis Vitton dans l'ascenseur
la l'heure où la femme de ménage passe
pour aller dans faire le ménage dans le
cabinet d'avocat ça c'est magnifique.
Vous l'avez jamais fait ça ça marche un
peu moins bien. On y va direct nor. On a
notre petite On a notre petit stagiaire
de On a on a notre petit stagiaire dans
l'équipe qui fait le tout gentil qui
passe partout.
Premier de la classe. Faudra qu'on te
montre une photo mais tu vas comprendre.
Il s'appelle Kevin. Non
non non.
Alors question internet. Quels sont
leurs sites d'information/formation
au hacking et pour compléter comment
s'informe-t-il en général ?
D'accord. Euh on en fait une catégorie
chacun là si tu veux. Euh veille techno,
c'est suivre les conférences
aujourd'hui. Tout est gratuit puisque
c'est dans l'esprit du de la commune.
C'est la Defcon. Il y a tous les il y a
toutes les présentation en replay sur
YouTube avec les tal que enfin c'est des
fois c'est des conférences d' 1h30 avec
tout le détail technique. Derrière il y
a le petit article qui publie avec le
tuto, les outils qui ont été développés.
En terme de veille vraiment sur les
nouvelles vulles, c'est pas mal. Il y a
la blackat,
il y a le HAC, enfin anciennement lui du
hack, mais mine de rien, on n' pas à
rougir. Le
H, il y a le Chaos Computer Club. Enfin,
il y a Allemagne,
faut se renseigner sur tous les
événements de sécurité finalement.
Euh et euh à défaut de pouvoir y aller
regarder les replay ou suivre les les
live streams parce que même sur la SP
streaming ça te couper et je dévis un
peu.
C'est c'est pas ça devient pas un peu la
de l'abus les les tarifs pour certaines
conférences de cybersécurité ? Quand tu
es obligé de lâcher 1500 € euh
qu'est-ce qu'on avait eu ? On avait pété
un plomb
euh les conférences de Kevin Mitnick à
50 60000 dollars.
Ah ouais ouais ça ça c'était du troll.
C'est ça génie
la la Black 4at je crois que c'est cher
la Black 4at. Oui, c'était sur la partie
sponsoring aussi où le le le coût du
sponsoring, je crois s levé à 50000
50000 dollars. Mais en fait, bah ça
c'est la
tu ouvres une nouvelle boîte qui est bah
voilà ben la transition du coup du
milieu du hacking et donc de la
cybersécurité
et en fait le l'aspect business qui en
découle aujourd'hui. Donc qu'est-ce qui
se passe quand tu fais rentrer de la
gloire et de l'argent dans un milieu ?
forcément du coup tuas tu as cette
transformation d'un milieu qui était
initialement beaucoup plus communautaire
open et bon bah il y a pas forcément
réellement d'argent à se faire donc on
est tous copains à un milieu où bah
effectivement bah maintenant on a des
exigences business et du sponsorship
pour tout ça non ça pourrit tout
le problème c'est qu'il y a pas de
raison que ce soit le cas il y a
tellement de enfin il y a un boulot
monstre en fait il y a une demande qui
est ça répond ça revient répond à la
question de tout à l'heure aussi c'est
est-ce qu'il y a de la progression à
l'échelle nationale oui il y a une
progression
Lanc enfin désolé si c'est pas corporate
mais tire enfin tire la tire la culotte
non ça se dit le chef d'orchestre et
donne la tendance de progression
se sortir les doigts du cul
avec les corps d'armé mais là-dessus on
voit en terme de prise de conscience qu'
il y a eu du boulot il y a eu du
matraquage de sensibilisation aussi qui
s'est fait dans la douleur pour certain
mais donc il y a il y a tellement de
boulot qu'il y a aucune raison d'être
dans la concurrence en fait ou de
chercher à se brander
Maurice ou Toto, on s'en fiche.
On on échange avec les entreprises que
ce soit des PM de Z des groupes du 440
juste en restant à l'échelle nationale
sans partir route Atlantique ou sur
l'Asie ou que sais-je, il y a un bou il
y a un taf monstre et
il y a encore des années de travail
avant que le sujet soit suffisamment
vulgarisé, rendu accessible à tout le
monde aussi en terme de coût parce
qu'effectivement ça donne lieu à des
débords sur la la partie prestation qui
enfin quand tu vends des prestations
à plusieurs de milliers d'euros la
journée homme et que des fois tu passes
derrière avec un tarif moindre et que tu
constates le travail qui a été réalisé
et c'est honteux. Et ce genre de
dériffe, bah c'est pas grave, il faut
laisser faire ceux qui la font. Mais en
l'occurrence, il faut garder à l'esprit
que il y a du taf pour tout le monde.
Euh en l'occurrence, faut juste rester
intègre, euh continuer à former les
compétences et l'expertise technique
parce que c'est ça la valeur ajoutée du
client et savoir lui permettre enfin lui
donner les moyens de capitaliser parce
que aller chez quelqu'un vulgairement,
lui mettre le le nez dans la merde et
lui dire "Voilà ce qui va pas sur ton
système d'information, je reviens dans
un nom et débrouille-toi. Je t'ai donné
les préca." Voilà, il y a pas de
capitalisation, il va le vivre bah comme
une forme de traumatisme parce que bah
euh ouais, on m'a on m'a fait un rapport
d'échec finalement il s'appropriera pas
le sujet, il évoque il aura aucun
intérêt là-dessus et c'est ça aussi
qu'il faut changer.
Vous avez déjà fait HIP à Kim Paris ou
pas du tout ?
Non.
Question internet. Euh, vous seriez
capable de localiser le téléphone
chiffré de Benana ?
Je crois qu'il est dans son casque.
Eh euh pour revenir pour revenir pour
revenir à la première question, je la je
la relis quand même. Quels sont leurs
sites d'information formation hacking et
pour compléter comment s'informe-t-il en
général ?
Alors là-dessus, bah donc dans la
continuité de tous les sites et qui
agrèchent donc l'ensemble des
conférences de la communauté
là-dessus effectivement on peut avoir un
certain palier technique qui peut
repousser au premier abord et donc
effectivement bon c'est c'est payant.
Euh si on a les replay, bah parfois ça
peut être assez compliqué de de se taper
dedans. Euh dans tous les cas, sur la
partie réseaux sociaux, médias sociaux,
aujourd'hui la communauté est
extrêmement active sur Twitter. Donc
l'idée, c'est de transformer euh euh le
fil d'actualité Twitter plutôt en un fil
presque professionnel ou presque en tout
cas dédié à la cyber, histoire d'avoir
les dernières news et les dernières
techniques, les dernières conférences
pour se tenir à jour. Euh beaucoup de en
tout cas beaucoup de canaux de
communication parallèle qui soit sur
Twitter à suivre ou des choses comme ça.
Honnêtement, il y en a tellement que
j'ai du mal en
Ouais. J'ai vraiment du mal à les
distant faire de jaloux, c'est ça ?
Et oui aussi
apprentissage par contre. Ouais, il faut
peut-être
et donc oui voilà donc il y a ça il y a
les comités sur parallèle sur Discord,
Telegram, signal et cetera et par contre
sur la partie pur en mo apprentissage
aujourd'hui euh alors en entraînement
pur, on a les Français de Route Mi. Il
me semble que c'est basé à Londres,
c'est à The Box. On a un français exilé
en en Australie, Pentester Lab qui
réalise d'excellentes formations
notamment TR Akmi qui est sorti sur la
partie purement formation technique, on
a Port Swigger, les éditeurs de logiciel
de Burb Suite qui avait écrit le site le
livre The Web application Hacker on Book
version 2 et qui maintenant est en
version 3 purement gratuite avec des
détails techniques et des exercices en
ligne.
Euh
YouTube parce que enfin c'est un peu
laborieux YouTube en ce moment à ce
sujet là parce queil y a eu plusieurs
escl
des passionnés de de hacking qui
faisaient des démos tech de comment ils
avaient parce qu'il y a des il y a des
environnements virtuels d'entraînement
des vraies machines euh mis à
disposition pour l'entraînement. il
faisait des tutos vidéos de comment ils
arrivaient à résoudre et euh de
attaquants externes passaient admin de
la machine. Euh et ils sont fait ban
leur vidéo, ban leur compte. Donc c'est
un peu laborieux.
Il donnait il donnait la capacité à des
criminels.
Ouais.
Et paradoxalement YouTube a un programme
de bug buunty.
Vous connaissez Hermite ? Non. Vous
connaissez pas Hermite ?
Hermite, il avait une bonne base de
données.
Euh êtes-vous ? Question internet.
Êtes-vous vous-même visé par des
attaques
du fishing ? Je pense un petit peu comme
tout le monde
sur notre infrastructure web. Bon, on
essaie de de la limiter au maximum mais
effectivement quand on observe les logs,
oui, on voit on voit que on voit que ça
tape régulièrement. Après, ça fait
partie aussi du bruit de fond de
l'internet. Aujourd'hui, à partir du
moment où on a une exposition web, on a
des robots, des attaques ciblées qui qui
peuvent venir en tout sens
sans incident. C'est plus dans des
contextes où effectivement
les IP, les logs en général, c'est quel
pays ? Je t'ouvre pas euh tu as sur les
ratios, pas tant que ça sur les ratios
sur du web vraiment bot scan alors sur
des applicatifs web et sur donc ce qu'on
appelle le port SSH. C'est en gros un
port qui permet à un administrateur de
se connecter à une machine et de la de
la gérer. Euh sur les sur la partie
Firewall Web, on avait une répartition
allez, on avait al une grosse
prédominance
Chine, Russie. Après, bon
Iran
euh c'était c'était tu avais un 10 % sur
Iran, Afghanistan,
de la zone indienne aussi. On avait des
pays d'Afrique
mais enfin derrière on sait pas si c'est
du proxy, on sait pas si c'est la vraie
origine de la connexion. Donc au final
les dans les outils de sécurité quand
ils te prop ils te ils te vendent la
jolie web la jolie carte du monde avec
Oui. avec les effets LED.
Ouais c'est joli. C'est joli.
Franchement c'est sexy. Mais la valeur
ajoutée de réellement trace back le truc
ou autre ça te demande un poil plus de
travail d'investigation quand tu essayes
de remonter à la source. L'adresse de ce
site là, c'est quoi déjà ?
Euh, oh, il y en a plein parce que
il y en a un qui est super connu là.
Il y en a un qui est fait par Kasperski
aussi.
Ouais,
on l'avait mis en fond sur une photo,
c'était très joli. On a mis sur le
rétrojecteur chez toi.
J'ai utilisé le c'était le live des dos.
C'était Corben, le blogueur qui avait
sorti ça. Passe un un un gros bisou.
Il avait sorti une carte qui te permet
de visualiser en temps réel les attaques
par dénit de service dans le dans le
monde. Donc une attaque par des nit de
service. On prend plein de machines
enfin des nit de service distribué
pardon. On prend plein de machines et on
les balance vers une cible ou des cibles
juste dans le but de faire écrouler.
Vous avez jamais fait ça ? Vous créez
votre propre réseau de zombie ?
Des études par contre,
on a fait un projet de recherche et ça
nous a permis au passage de savoir si le
VPN qu'on utilisait était réellement
anonyme ou non et conservait les logs
et il conservait
euh ils ont pu nous ban parce qu'ils
savaient qu'on consommait
80 % de leur infrastructure interne. Ils
ne savaient pas ce qu'on faisait par
contre.
C'est déjà pas mal. Et le le projet de
recherche consistait effectivement euh à
savoir
cit quelle boîte
hein.
C'était quelle boîte ?
Ah, c'était un projet de recherche à la
maison un samedi soir et qui a duré tout
le weekend.
Mais ça consistait à savoir en combien
de temps tu pouvais te faire un botet en
scannant la plage IPv4 mondiale.
Ah ouais, toi tu es chaud quand même.
C'était Ben, on a eu la réponse et
c'était inquiétant.
Combien de temps ?
Euh Ah, il faut alors on virait la Live
Box parce que sinon elle crache dès que
tu faisais trop de si tu ouvrais trop de
flux TCP parallèle. Elle supportait pas
reboot, elle redémarre de manière
automatique. Donc on l'a viré, on a
branché à l'époque c'était l'arrivée de
la fibre 1 g en plus.
Donc derrière
c'est quoi ? T1, c'est ça de l'époque,
c'était du 1 Go down, c'était du 1 Go
descendant pour je crois c'était 200
Mant mais c'était déjà suffisant. Et
c'était le projet Zmap parce que ZMAP te
permet de de scanner des très grandes
rang d'IP publ à des vitesses folles. Je
crois que c'est le je sais plus si c'est
Cambridge ou le MIT qui a fait un
travail d'analyse et aujourd'hui en plus
ça a donné les évolutions donnent lieu
bah au moteur de recherche Shudan par
exemple. Shodan qui est le moteur de
recherche de failles de sécurité,
bah qui indexe tout ce qu'il y a sur
internet en temps réel sur à l'échelle
mondiale. Donc quand tu trouves une
faille et que tu veux savoir bah par
exemple, j'ai trouvé une faille sur un
un décodeur Dreambox version truc, tu
tapes sur Shodan puis tu sais combien tu
as d'instances dans le monde exposé sur
internet. Ouais.
Question internet.
Euh OK. Pour rebondir sur les choix
techniques, entre parenthèses de
messagerie, utiliser qu'utilisez-vous
personnellement ? Vite, signal d'autres
choses
euh signal
et sur du nom corpo ou pro Discord.
C'est pas après c'est pas des choix
enfin comment dire par rapport à Discord
c'est voilà c'est du c'est du non corpo,
ça nous permet d'avoir des échanges
étant donné qu'il y a beaucoup de
personnes mais une grande partie de la
communauté sur Discord ça permet
vraiment d'avoir le premier canal
aujourd'hui sur les solutions techniques
qui sont mises à disposition du grand
public sur les aspects messageries
sécurisé
on a éliminé un petit peu WhatsApp de
l'équation
et ce qui nous reste effectivement les
français d'olvid un problème de bug
bounti
ça c'est ça c'est C'est c'est très
positif. Oui, il me semble qu'ils ont
communiqué ils ont communiqué en public
là-dessus
et euh et là-dessus après derrière on a
on a on a signal également qui est
énormément communiqué. Donc c'est vrai
qu'on connaît un petit peu moins signal
beaucoup plus. Est-ce qu'on a procédé à
analyser leur code source en profondeur
?
Non. Est-ce qu'on a joué avec ?
Oui. Est-ce qu'on a trouvé des choses
intéressantes ?
On peut pas dire
on peut pas le dire.
Question internet. Quelle est votre
principale difficulté en ce moment ?
Ressources, qualité, problèmes
techniques, vol de données utilisateur,
renseignement industriel entre
parenthèses. Quelles attaques
aujourd'hui vous redoutez le plus ?
Euh alors là, c'est je pense plus
par-être stress ou inquiétude
personnelle. Moi, c'est les réponses à
incident.
Aller voir les gens et enfin les process
d'annonce enfin ils sont déprimants en
fait. C'est parce qu'on on sort du
contexte technique, on là on voit les
impacts humains mesurables quoi.
Et
ça c'est très important ce que tu
soulignes là.
C'est c'est euh
question internet. Pegasus, Toxnet et
cetera. Aucune des cybermveillances
proviennent de la France. Que fait la
France en cyber ? Alors je rajouterai,
il y avait Babar chez nous. Mais bon, fa
passon vous avez ça te fait marrer toi.
Tu veux nous parler de barbar ?
que fait la Attends, je réponds à la
question. Que fait la France ? Euh
euh aujourd'hui c'est sujet si vraiment
de RD de stratégie euh cyber qui
donnerait un edge vis-à-vis des final
c'est c'est un format un peu de
dissuasion aussi au passage hein de
savoir qu'il y a de la puissance de de
frappe à l'échelle nationale. Bah c'est
porté par c'est porté par les différents
corps d'armé puisque qui plus est je
sais que la DGSE et la c'est
renseignement intérieur c'est
DGSI
DGSI ils ont leur savoir et ils ont leur
leur méthodo
euh sur la partie sur les autres sujets
après bon sur
on sait pas en fait on a pas de
visibilité
on a pu leur demander et le discours
officiel bah
ils sont aimables à la DGSI ou pas qui
est le plus aimable Mme c'est la DGSI ou
la DGSE
c'est comme partout tu peux tomber sur
des cons partout.
Oh qu'est-ce que vous êtes
C'était corpau ça ?
Alors ouais c'était très corpo. Alors le
salaire il est meilleur où ? À
l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur ?
Euh je me suis pas renseigné.
Victor tu es dans tu sais pas euh quelle
est la place du cyber pour l'avancée de
la course spatiale ?
Alors, il y a eu il y a eu il y a pas
vraiment pas la date exacte en tête, il
me semble c'était il y a 2 ou 3 ans, une
compétition donc un Capture the Flag,
donc une une compétition sur un
environnement maîtrisé,
c'est ça de de hacking visant à capturer
un drapeau. Donc souvent un petit
fichier texte quelque part sur une
machine qu'on doit compromettre. Je il
me semble qu'à l'époque, il y a eu une
compétition sur un satellite où le but
était effectivement initialement de ah
bah reproduire alors euh alors
comprendre et reproduire le protocole de
communication entre une station et un
satellite, trouver une vulnérabilité
dans ce protocole de communication pour
accéder au satellite et une fois dans le
satellite commandre le comment
comprendre comment le satellite
fonctionne pour être capable de modifier
son orbite et par exemple je sais pas
simuler un crash sur telle zone de la
planète. Donc oui, c'est important. Euh
et aujourd'hui, il me semble qu'il y a
des satellites qui sont mis à
disposition du grand public pour à des à
des fins purement scientifiques, donc à
des fins de curiosité. Euh au vu du de
l'enjeu que représentent les satellites
par rapport à un aspect géopolitique et
défense, défense et armée, oui, c'est
crucial par rapport à de l'exploration
spatiale à proprement dit. Pour moi,
étant donné qu'on est vraiment au
prémiss des des débuts de des premiers
pas de l'homme à travers à travers
l'espace, c'est difficile à dire, mais
Infin, ça sera toujours porté par des
enfin en tout cas de la façon dont on
perçoit aujourd'hui, ça sera porté par
des systèmes informatiques. Et pour
l'anecdote, euh les soft enfin en tout
cas les les logiciels qui sont utilisés
dans l'espace en général ou même sur des
sur des systèmes critiques, on essaie de
réduire leur complexité.
On essaie pour éviter de réduire
justement le la quantité de bug qu'on
peut avoir en production. Donc
l'exemple du buffer overflow sur la
fusée, il y a c'était c'était Arian quoi
explique le
mais j'essaie déjà de retrouver juste le
programme spatial. Tu t'en souviens ou
pas ? C'était quel fusé avait explosé à
cause donc alors techniquement on
appelle ça un buffer overflow. C'est un
challenger. Non,
je saurais pas te dire et je sais que
sur le plan technique c'était un buffer
overflow donc un dépassement de mémoire
tampon. En gros, c'est une problématique
technique mais dont aujourd'hui nous on
sert dans un contexte de lorsqu'on
cherche une vulnérabilité, si on tombe
sur un buffer overflow, ben on est
content parce que globalement ça nous
permet derrière on évitera, je fais
l'impasse he sur tous les sur tout le
sur tout le détail euh d'arriver
potentiellement à avoir une un accès
distant sur l'applicatif ou sur le
serveur qui héberge le programme qui a
cette vulnérabilité de buffer overflow.
en l'occurrence, ça avait fait exploser
la fusée cette problématique technique.
Donc le sujet cyber, il reste d'ordre
dans le sens où bah lorsqu'on constate
quelque chose qui potentiellement va
déclencher ce qu'on appelle une
indisponibilité de service, une fusée
qui explose, c'est une indisponibilité
de service.
Il faut il faut faire un
P àor
Arian 5.
Arian 5. Génial.
Merci. Merci. Qui ?
Question internet,
230000 € c'est pas peu cher pour truquer
une élection pour par un autre état.
Est-ce que le bug Bunti a 230000 balles
chez les Suisses ?
C'est la faille.
Ah, c'est de la faille.
Le le modèle économique du Bug Bunti,
c'est une rémunération à la faille. euh
faille vérifier, observer et mesurer de
manière cadrée.
Par contre, il il soulève quand même
enfin de la personne soulève quand même
une problématique intéresse, enfin pas
forcément une problématique mais en tout
cas une thématique qui est abordée en BL
Bounty, c'est quel est le le la balance
entre l'impact business d'une
vulnérabilité et le coût qu'on met dans
le bug buunty aujourd'hui ? Est-ce qu'on
peut se permettre de cracher dans la
soupe en disant c'est nul, on n pas on n
pas bien payé ? parce que ça fait partie
en tout cas de notre cœur d'activité.
Par contre, est-ce que il y a une
discrepancy, donc une une différence, un
déséquilibre entre ce qu'on peut
observer en terme de cricité technique
et ce qui est effectivement mis en tant
en terme de ressources financières par
une entreprise ? Oui, il y a des il y a
de clair déséquilibre.
La l'entité que tu cherchais tout à
l'heure, c'est la SGDSN.
C'est ce qui est censé protéger les
ministres. Non.
D'accord. J'ai mal révisé mon son.
Les acronymes, c'est affreux. Tu as vu
déjà le nom qu'on utilise nous quand tu
pars dans les instances ?
Ils sont en train de faire des blagues.
Quelles sont les trois principales
protections individuelles, informatiques
que les utilisateurs devraient appliquer
sur leur ordi smartphone ? On a déjà
passé ça. Que pens que pensent ils en
pensent quoi des campus cyber ?
Bah à mon sens, c'est une bonne démarche
dans le sens où enfin ça fait du c'est
horrible. Bah c'est une bonne démarche
parce que tu vois, on parlait tout à
l'heure de la des aspects concurrentiels
qui avaient pas lieu d'êtes sur les
sujets campus cyber en l'occurrence si
ça permet de rapprocher les entreprises
parce que chacun a son savoir-faire. Le
gars qui va révolutionner toute la cyber
en France tout seul, il existe pas. Euh
c'est tellement une spécialité
et voilà. Donc c'est tellement
transverse que enfin au même titre que
dans un jeu vidéo, on reste des gamers
dans l'âme. Chacun a ses skills. Tu vas
faire le max, tu vas combo possible, tu
fais tu montes ta team.
Mais dans ta team,
tout le monde doit avoir sa spécialité.
Bah c'est ça. Il faut arriver à trouver
un modèle complémentaire sinon bah
et sans ego et sans ego.
On appelle on appelle ça l' pénis entre
mais c'est exactement ça.
C'est ça.
Sinon, tu prends la grosse tête et
question internet. Bonjour. Avez-vous vu
le bureau des légendes ? À quel point la
série sur le plan hacking est-elle
réaliste ?
Alors, on nous a fait des réponses.
Je me suis mis à jour.
Ah ouais,
j'en a été jusqu'à la 4 et puis après
la saison 4.
Ouais. Euh, faut pas que je spoile hein.
Euh oh, il y a il y a il y a certains il
y a certaines incohérences. Il y a des
Il faudrait une pause de 5 minutes pour
les ressourcer. Tu as tu dis
je sais il y a des trucs qui m'ont fait
genre il y a des trucs qui m'ont fait
ticker pendant l'instant mais je suis
laisse-moi un peu de temps, ça va me
revenir. Le hacking de la prison dans
monsieur robot. Tu l'as vu celui-là
? Ah avec le Bluetooth.
Alors euh Mister Bot si tu prends
vraiment la série dans son entier, c'est
plausible.
Si tu as le temps et l'argent hein.
C'est plausible. Par contre est-ce que
c'est techniquement vraiment réalisable
? Pas forcément. Par contre, oui, elle a
elle a eu le elle a eu le le mérite
d'avoir mis en valeur des scénarios qui
étaient plausibles.
Vous avez quel distrip sur Linux ?
C'était c'est du Kalix.
Ouais, on enfin on a grandi avec back
c'était backtrack et c euh
c'était Slack.
Parot, vous utilisez un peu ou pas du
tout ?
Euh j'ai fait un po il y a fort
longtemps. Il y a 7 ans.
Quentin ou Ouais ouais Quentin bossa
avec. Ouais,
on avait un apprenti qui bossait avec
quoi c'est kifkif hein. C'est après
c'est les goûts et les couleurs de toute
façon entre au moment de l'installe et 2
mois plus tard quand tu as commencé à
partir sur tous les derniers tout le
enfin tous les derniers outils qui
sortent sur Geit of H ça ressemble plus
à
à ce que tu as installé.
Question de Néofit. Pour installer Linux
pour un néofit pas si simple. Est-ce
qu'il y a des tutos disponibles ? Oui.
Euh bah sur si part sur Cali il veut
Linux ou une distribution de sécurité ?
Il veut installer Linux.
sur duun, il y a les tutos qui existent
depuis des années pour démarrer, c'est
très bien. Et sur un Linux orienté CQ,
il y a les tutos sur Cali.
Après, c'est peut-être juste un petit
peu hardware dépendant, mais bon,
aujourd'hui, il y a quand même un bon
support sur la plupart du matériel. Donc
parler
question question internet. Bonjour. Que
pensent-t-il du cloud ? Microsoft AWS
utilisé et poussé par des grands groupes
français, y compris par des entités
stratégiques entre parenthèses industrie
défense quit des labels Secnum Cloud.
On va Alibaba Cloud et du scandale de la
semaine dernière. On va parler agrément
HDS et Microsoft. Euh aujourd'hui, il
faut alors il y a quand même quelque
chose qui est honorable et qu'on observe
de en tant qu'acqueur éthique euh que ce
soit du Microsoft, du AWS, euh même
Alibaba. Qui d'autre fait du cloud ?
J'en oublie.
Czy Cloud.
Cos cloud Mais ils ont pas de programme
de Bugby Buunty, je crois. Je suis pas
sûr. Mais l'aspect budget alloué à la CQ
et versement de prime, il a explosé. Euh
paradoxalement, le nombre de failles
mises en évidence sur les services dans
le cloud euh ils ont souffert enfin AWS
c'est beaucoup plus confidentiel à ce
sujet puisque c'est très privé et et sur
les aspects recherche et désengagement
de confidentialité de background check
fort euh sur la partie Google, on oublie
Google euh donc quand on oublie non
Google et Microsoft ils ont quand même
une politique très transparente sur
combien ils reverent au chasseur comment
ils gèent les problématiqu sécuritaire.
Ça n'empêche que même si tu vois, il y a
il y a eu un souci chez Azur il y a pas
longtemps euh enfin il y en a eu un il y
a une semaine et il y en a eu un il y a
2 mois. Celui d' mois, le problème c'est
que ça a été repris sur le plan
médiatique en mode grosse fuite de
données sur les services dans le cloud
Cosmos DB des millions de clients
concernés. Ça c'est ce qui a été
médiatisé. Et sur le plan technique, il
s'agissait il s'agissait d'une remontée
d'une boîte.
On al faudra vérifier, je me prends pas
le risque de où est-ce qu'elle est
géographiquement mais du même style que
nous deux en mode on vient sur votre
programme de weboutil, on vous remonte
la faille, on vous dit comment la
corriger et on repart avec les sous. OK
mais en l'occurrence la manière dont ça
a été médiatisé derrière c'est fuite de
données million. Donc ça ça alimente
juste un un côté anxiogène collectif.
Ça vaccine les entreprises pour
communiquer et aller se faire aider. Ah
bah derrière tu revends toute la
souveraineté du monde en disant oster
français autre. Sur l'aspect hébergement
en France sur des environnements
sécurisé ou autres. Il y a des acteurs
français qui font ça très bien. Euh mais
par contre quand tu poses la question
aux entreprises, pourquoi vous partez
dans le cloud cloud hybride cloud total
externalisation complète ? Pourquoi
est-ce qu'on va mettre je crois que
c'est pour les GIO de les GIO de Paris
c'est 2024.
J de Paris, ça part ça enfin le le
scandale c'est pourquoi ça part chez
chez Alibaba Cloud en ce moment quoi.
Bah écoute bah en fait c'est pas cher,
c'est économique
et s'agresse bien.
Donc sur l'aspect SQ, ils sont enfin ils
sont bons hein. Mais derrière quel enfin
l'aspect légitimité et souveraineté moi
je préfère avoir la donnée à la maison
mais enfin dans le sens héberge soit
hébergement
tu t'éberges toi-même. Voilà
hébergement soi-même. Après sur une
boîte qui a des problématiques de
volumétrie, il y a des acteurs français
de confiance.
Lesquels ? Au VH.
Euh au VH ou ils sont très bien.
Quand ça crame pas
là, tu trolles.
Bah ils en ont ils sont fait ils en ont
souffert.
Attends, ils sont fait troller par les
Allemands. Tu imagines même pas le level
du parquet de bois, quoi.
J'ai pas suivi ça.
Ah ouais ouais. Bon, passons détail. Euh
euh et euh il y a euh en plus le SECNUM
Cloud, je crois que ça erreur le alors
le sujet on l'a pas bossé dans le fond
parce qu'on est historiquement plus sur
des trucs normatif ISO 27001, c'est des
exigences sécurité pour des hébergeurs,
pour euh euh des data centers ou pour
des équipes informatiques. C'est que Num
Cloud, on a moins bossé. Visiblement, ça
a l'air exigeant en terme de mise en
conformité. Vu que ça s'oriente sur de
la gouvernance, c'est moins de la
technique, je t'avoue que on a pris un
petit peu de recul et on met moins le
nez dedans, quoi.
On a parlé des journalistes là ou des
journalistes qui font monter des trucs
qui ne comprennent pas.
Pour vous, les les trois meilleurs
journalistes français qui parlent de la
Tex, c'est lesquels ?
Alors, c'est difficile à dire. On a on a
eu le plaisir de rencontrer quelques-uns
au fic.
Lesquels ?
Je t'avoue que les les noms, c'est
difficile. On va
Jean-Marc Manac.
Dans notre milieu, on se connaît tous
par nos pseudos. Donc je t'avoue que les
noms et les prénoms c'est
Jeanmarc Manac. Manac
le gars le gars de qui fait cybergerre
de Numéama.
On a parlé avec Lic et je suis désolé,
j'ai oublié son prénom
et son nom de famille. C'est honteux.
Moi aussi.
Il fait un super taf en mode c'est
vulgarisé, il restitue correctement,
c'est du factuel. Enfin, tu sais que tu
lis un papier qui est agréable, qui est
accessible et sur lequel il y a pas eu
de raccourci ou d'interprétation. Quoi ?
Il ressembla à quoi ? C'est je euh
d'amens d'amens quelque chose comme ça.
Ça va en revenir, t'inquiète, je l'ai.
My menens Manens.
Question internet. Les invités ont-ils
des boutons qui poussent lorsque les
politiques souhaitent légiférer le web
entre parenthèses, la loi Avia, la Nem
loi sécurité, j'en passe,
ça va. Adopis, Opa pipa,
mais finira enfin on on se on trouvera
ça un peu plus original lorsqu'ils
commenceront à s'axer sur les
cryptomonnaies. On verra ce qu'ils vont
nous pondre là-dessus aussi.
Sur les cryptonnaies là, qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ?
Sur le plan solution euh décorrélé de
l'aspect financier spéculatif. Euh sur
le plan techno, euh c'est une tuis ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire avec. Il y a des
possibilités en terme de de mode de
fonctionnement qui sont vraiment super
intéressantes sur des cas d'usage,
l'aspect acte acte notarié, le coût des
assurances décentralisées et en fait tu
arrives à enfin oui c'est comme son nom
l'indique he tu casses un une autorité
une autorité un peu sur un format
araignée toile d'araignée central qui
gère tout l'écosystème un format où
personne finalement ne représente une
autorité puisque c'est plus sur un mode
soit alors consensus collectif
pre de travail. Derrière, tu as toutes
les spécificités techniques où il
faudrait un expert pour mieux l'exposer
que nous. Mais sur le plan, ce que ça va
amener si on arrive réellement à le
démocratiser, à vulgariser parce que là
on est quand même encore un peu sur
l'orly adoption d'une certaine manière
quoi.
L'orly adoption c'est interdit en
français, c'est
euh
adoption prématuré.
L'adoption prématurée. Non
les les phases les phrases les premières
phases
le début.
Tu veux rajouter quelque chose sur les
cryptos ? On fera une émission spéciale
crypto. D'ailleurs, vous voulez, vous
avez fait un peu de tune avec les
crypto,
vous êtes pas obligé de répondre non
plus. Oui oui avec déclaration FL taxe
euh les 30 % avant que c'était avant
avant c'était pas 30 % c'était 178 plus
en fonction du du taux d'imposition et
sur la plusvalue
sur la plusvalue ouais
avec les super fichiers Excel que tu
peux pas mettre parce que derrière ils
sont limités à 25 lignes sur les
déclarations d'impôts au niveau des
allers-retours. Donc dès que si tu fais
plus de 25 fois BTC USD et que tu es
repassé en en en monnaie fiducière, bah
sur la déclaration, tu es tu es obligé
de faire un mail à part. Enfin, c'est un
bordel monstre.
Tu comme quoi tu vois, on est sur
l'adoption, on est sur le début.
Alors, question. La dimension
psychologique d'une cyberattaque ne doit
pas être négligée. Point
d'interrogation. Qu'en pensez-vous
pour que pensez-vous pouvoir rentrer ?
Bon, ça tient pas. Remettre les
serveurs, on s'en fout.
Euh
po
Alors, quelle question ? Que pensent-il
de la série Monsieur Robot ?
Trop sympa.
La musique est bonne.
La musique est excellente composée par
change de NCIS. Je sais pas si tu
souviens avec la quand tu as tapé là.
Ouais, ils étaient à deux sur le
clavier. ou ouais ou Alors ça c'est une
question euh
entre nous
la prise de drogue dans la dans la
communauté,
est-ce que ça s'est calmé ? Ça s'est pas
calmé ? Est-ce qu'il y a toujours des
mecs qui carburent à gogo ? Est-ce que
ça fume plus que de la weed ? Il faut
pas consommer de drogue ? Il y a des
messages à passer ? Oui ou non ?
Pas de commentaire.
Très trop difficile à quantifier pour
être pour être factuel.
Si je dois me permettre si je plus dois
prendre du recul pour moi,
vous pourriez travailler à l'ambassade
chinoise tous les deux.
Non, si si je dois prendre du recul, je
dois dire que sur un sur un milieu
underground généralement
voilà, tuas tu as tendance à avoir des
dérives. Derrière, est-ce que on est
plus performant quand on taffe ? Est-ce
que quels impacts ça peut avoir
réellement derrière ? Nous aujourd'hui,
on privilégie la longévité et le fait en
fait de pas se cramer les neurones. Ça
souvent ça
alors après bah effectivement enfin il y
a il y a
on bosse déjà 80 he par semaine. Tu
imagines on rajoute au truc qu'on va
finir
dans 5 ans. On est fini quoi.
Ouais il y en a qui bossent plus de 80
heures par semaine hein. Après voilà, il
y a la enfin pour moi la la vraie
question sous centre c'est OK très bien,
il y a peut-être de la partie récréative
mais le drive enfin le driver le moteur
principal ça doit être la passion
et la passion avant l'argent la passion
avant l'gène de vie et qui va avec
l'hygiène de vie qui va avec essayer de
faire gave le bien dormir et ainsi de
suite.
Ça on se mentirait si on si on disait
qu'on était exemplaire.
Tu as vu la tête ?
C'est vrai qu'on a cette exclusivité.
Que pens-il des cryptomonnaies ? On a
déjà parlé ? Non, on voulait rajouter un
petit mot.
C'est c'est prometteur derrière. Après,
bon, il y a tous les enjeux. Certaines
personnes soulèvent la problématique
écologique, d'autres soulèv les
problématiques liées à l'aspect
financier des randomware et cetera.
Bref, il y a beaucoup de controverses.
La tech est très sympa. Il y a beaucoup
à faire et ça pourra permettre de
réaliser de belles choses et peut-être
de décentraliser un petit peu le pouvoir
et de le remettre.
Ça va nous donner un nouveau terrain de
jeu.
Ouais. la blockchain, on n pas enfin la
CQ commence à s'y porter hein. Niveau
bug bunty, tu en as de plus en plus de
tu as de plus en plus de programmes. Ça
s'improvise pas parce qu'il faut enfin
il faudrait qu'on prenne 3 4 mois pour
euh vraiment tafer le dossier et être
hâte de se dire "OK, ça te donne mieux à
quel enfin c'est quoi le nouveau terrain
de jeu et c'est finalement c'est quoi
les nouveaux vecteurs d'attaque qui sont
spécifiques à cette techno quoi parce
que ça aussi tu as la même chose sur la
big data. Big data, on parle beaucoup de
vulnérabilité technique et cetera, mais
tout ce qui est agrégat de données
massives, ça.
On a des scénarios d'attaque qui te
demande pas de compéten technique et tu
peux faire des trucs monstrueux avec.
Quo tu aspires tout,
hein ?
Tu aspires tout ?
Non, derrière en fait euh aujourd'hui,
on est en train de faire une confiance
aveugle à la donnée et on s'est rendu
compte que typiquement tu prends par
exemple une banque, elle va agréger
énormément de données sur ses clients à
partir de cet agrégat de tout ton tout
transactionnel par exemple sur ton
compte bancaire.
Bien sûr qui n'est pas anonymisé.
euh ils sont capables de faire des
offres commerciales
ciblées puisque aujourd'hui c'est
l'intérêt, ça permet de faire aussi
enfin cet agrégat donné et de
transactionnel de ce que tu fais de tes
comportements sur ton compte bancaire
par exemple pour ta banque, c'est de
pouvoir mieux te cibler derrière sur les
produits qu'elle va te vendre, sur ce
qu'elle va te proposer et sur ce qu'elle
va te conseiller. Imagine juste pour le
troll, tu prends ton compte en banque,
tu as pas de compéten technique mais
pendant un mois, tu t'amuses à retirer.
Donc tu le provisionnes avec 5000 € tu
t'amuses à retirer tous les jours 5000,
remettre les 5000. Le lendemain tu
retires les 5000, tu remets les 5000. À
la fin du mois, tu seras toujours à 5000
€. Pourtant tu as tu auras créé des
mouvements erratiques.
On va te proposer des assurances pour
Porsche. C'est ça. Bien vu mec. Le c'est
vérifié dans certains cas de figure. La
donnée est agrégée de manière
automatique mais la cohérence des
interprétations qui sont fait à partir
des ce qu'on appelle les datasets. Donc
c'est ces gros volumes de données où on
va déclencher des actions, ça il y a pas
forcément de sécurité. Donc ça déclenche
des effets de bord et les gars qui
voudront se pencher sur ces sujets de
recherche, il y a des trucs super sympas
à trouver. En parlant de data euh de de
téléphone portable, de Facebook installé
sur votre téléphone portable et autres
petites application de joyeuseté pour
vous consommer le le cerveau,
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fait que
nos téléphones quand ils sont avec nous,
ils nous écoutent pour nous refiler de
la pub ? Je prends un exemple. Je me
suis amusé à faire écouter à mon
téléphone des bruits de quinte de tout
pour voir si ensuite on allait me
proposer des pubs pour du paracétamol,
des pastilles et j'en passais des
meilleurs. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ça ? Qu'est-ce quelle mesure proactiv
vous utilisez chez vous pour éviter
d'être lu ou d'être compris par des
sociétés étrangères ?
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? C'est de
l'intrusion ? C'est pas de l'intrusion ?
C'est un prix à payer pour utiliser
Facebook ou d'autres ? Euh
bah c'est ça. Oui, c'est Tu as vu la
vidéo du grand JD peut-être ? Ça te dit
quelque chose.
On l' On l'avait vu aussi en
l'occurrence c'est la vérité du si c'est
gratuit c'est toi le produit.
Gros Google, c'est ça la vidéo
hein.
Non, vous connaissez pas cette vidéo là
?
Non.
Vous connaissez pas la vidéo et gros
Google ?
Non.
Faut essayer. Cel est pas mal. Vas-y
continue, je t'ai coupé. Désolé.
Et sur la partie si c'est gratuit cette
fois le produit, ça a jamais été un
secret.
Regarde
nous nous c'est gratuit. Oui,
mais notre communauté nous finance.
C'est en fait c'est pas si gratuit que
ça. C'est ça. Le matos que vous voyez,
ça coûte un blat, un bras, les salaires
ains de suite, les cotisations. Sauf que
sauf que
tu vois Facebook se dire "On va faire ça
?"
Non.
[Musique]
Après, tu soulèves aussi le le le la
thématique de la conscience.
Ouais.
Alors là, ça c'est une question qui m'a
l'air un peu alambiqué mais je vais la
poser quand même. Avez-vous entendu
parler des virus logés dans les mémoires
des cartes graphique et du coup
indétectable par les logiciels antivirus
?
Euh oui, il y a eu du travail de RD fait
de manière assez récente là-dessus.
C'est très sympa. Euh pour moi, ça ouvre
le enfin ça ouvre aussi le champ plus un
petit peu plus général de euh on est
dans un environnement tech, on a des
composants, chacun de ces composants
maintenant est relativement intelligent,
a euh une capacité de d'en d'en alors
d'embarquer, donc d'emport de de mémoire
et de stockage d'intrôleurs clavier, tu
as vu les contrôleurs clavier pareil et
d'instruction. Et en fait aujourd'hui
euh alors là en l'occurrence c'est
utilisé dans le dans le cadre d'une
méthode d'exécution. Donc on stock il me
semble des instructions en mémoire sur
le du GPU comme ça on contourne
l'antivirus parce que il y a pas de
solution antivirale aujourd'hui qui
scann C'est ça qui scanne la partie
mémoire de la carte graphique. C'est
dans la VRAM enfin c'est la la mémoire
principale c'est de la RAM et côté vidéo
c'est de la VRAM. Donc c'est vraiment
les barrettes enfin les barrettes façon
de parler mais les puces mémoires sur la
carte graphique et c'est il y a bien une
segmentation côté système d'exploitation
entre les deux. Et derrière en fait tu
avais d'autres personnes qui avaient
fait des travaux de recherche bah
justement sur tout l'IoT, donc les
objets connectés, euh la mémoire d'un
périphérique clavier, la mémoire d'un
périphérique de stockage de disque dur
et en fait comment est-ce que tu es
capable de devenir persistant sur ces
périphériques là ? C'estàd que très bien
on prend un cas on prend un cas critique
rend somewh très bien on a on a tout
wipé on a wipé les on a on a effacé tous
les disques durs remise à zéro
oninstalle tout
ça
ouais mais le micro le microcontrôleur
du du disque dur il est où
il est physique
le hard le hard c'est ce qu'il y a de
pire hein hardware. On a on a quelqu'un
de très brillant en François.
Moi j'en connais un d'ailleurs. Ils se
font les neones là-dessus. Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez que du fait qu'il y ait pas
des résines transparentes sur les
processeurs ? Qu'est-ce que tu as ?
Comment ça résine trans ?
Tu prends ton processeur euh il est tout
noir, tu peux pas le regarder au
microscope.
Ouais,
c'est l'aspect open source de si si tu
peux si tu peux. les les travaux de
recherche là-dessus où ils font des
découpages laser et ils font des enfin
c'est la en reverse en ingénierie
inversée là-dessus euh espionnage
industriel il y a tout ce que enfin je
sur Google il y a des trucs très
intéressants effectivement qui sont
d'origine majoritairement des pays de
certains pays d'Asie
j'ai pas donné de nom mais c'est un
enfin ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
c'est c'est oufissime quoi. Ouais.
Et par contre, il me semble alors je
j'avais j'avais lu un article sur Y
Combinator, donc c'est Hacker News, là
au sujet de en fait de des machines qui
permettent de produire justement tous
ces tous ces tous ces circuits imprimés.
Et aujourd'hui en fait la tech qui
permet de produire ces circuits
imprimés, c'est il y a un fabricant qui
crée les machines qui permettent de
créer ces circuits ces circuits imprimés
derrière là. Et en fait, il y a un
embargo qui est colossal sur cette tech
là parce qu'elle est le elle serait le
sujet euh de 30 ans presque de RED et
des forts conjoints de Intel AMD de du
gouvernement américain. Donc en fait, il
y a une quantité d'argent monstrueuse
qui a été faite là-dedans qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont presque le
monopole en fait sur sur ça et sur les
circuits imprimés. Et donc aujourd'hui
la problématique enfin qui a été
partiellement solvée dans le software où
effectivement maintenant on donne
aujourd'hui le on peut accéder à du code
source avec l'open source sur l'open
hardware on va avoir beaucoup beaucoup
de retard je pense et de difficulté à à
adapter le mouvement open source sur
l'open hardware. sur comment c'est fait
ce travail-là. Sauf erreur, tu as le euh
Deusx Silicium qui est un enfin c'est un
taré de l'électronique et ultra brillant
euh qui a fait taré pas taré brillant.
Tu le vois pas comme positif ?
Si si, mais il y a des gens qui comprend
ah qui vont être secondaux. Il est
brillantissime. Et sur l'une de ces
vidéos, il fait la démonstration de
comment il vient justement le petit case
de ta puce, tu viens le faire fondre et
qu'est-ce qu'il y a en dessous ? Comment
s'est récupéré ? commencer à analyser et
euh très intéressant enfin pour ceux qui
seraient curieux.
Alors euh VPN, vous utilisez quoi comme
VPN chez vous ?
Euh bah on bah on en a plusieurs. On est
avec du open VPN et c'est sur nos
infrastructures. C'est pas on passe pas
par un un un fournisseur tire.
Donc pas de cascading, neuroouting tor
plus toup VPN. Non,
Tor, on l'utilise que sur de la veille
pour aller voir les tendances de ski.
Vous avez confiance en tort ou pas ?
Mais euh
je vois Victor rigoler.
Tu as autant
Ah non, Victor a rigolé. Le premier
c'est à Victire de répondre.
Bah je te laisserai taper le truc quand
quand je te quand je t'jun dans le son.
Wouh tort. C'est c'est c'est le darknet,
c'est incroyable. Puis en fait quand tu
deviens un petit peu plus mature et que
tu te dis ben c'est quand même
intéressant de savoir d'où vient
l'argent. Et en fait, j'ai appris à
l'époque que oui, c'était 80 %
des subventions de tort qui venaient de
la défense, c'est 80 %, c'est peut-être
un peu moins. Non.
Alors, à l'époque, j'avais vu le le ce
chiffre là. Par contre, je suis
complètement d'accord sur le fait qu'il
faut réval parle gentiment parce que la
fondation Thort là c'est un petit peu
son
et alors donc du coup effectivement je
m'étais posé la question mais pourquoi
est-ce que un réseau qui serait utilisé
bah du coup par des activistes par des
gens sociés de la vie privée par des
criminels serait fondé majoritairement
par un gouvernement qui poursuit ces
criminels et je me suis c'est le serpent
qui se prend la queue
mais et du coup j'ai toujours pas
répondu à cette question donc c'est la
question que je me suis posé
Initialement, il y a eu des travaux de
recherche technique sur le fait bah
voilà comment est-ce qu'on peut
compromettre Thor, combien de n de
sorties faut-il posséder, qu'est-ce qui
se passe si tu as un autre sortie
malicieux,
Mozilla Z
escape Tales et cetera. Enfin, comment
est-ce que tu peux compromettre le
l'écosystème ? Ça a été fait, ça a été
compromis. Maintenant, est-ce qu'on dit
est-ce qu'on jette une solution
entièrement à la poubelle ? Oui, non.
Pour moi, ça fite pas, ça ne correspond
pas au modèle de la sécurité tel qu'on
l'aborde aujourd'hui parce que c'est la
sécurité, c'est une approche en couche.
Donc l'idée c'est de rejeter une couche
de sécurité. C'est une couche de
sécurité, c'est une couche de sécurité.
Donc est-ce qu'on prend une solution ?
On la met entièrement à la poubelle.
Non, ça fait partie d'un arsenal d'outil
qui est peut-être plus ou moins fiable
mais qui a son qui a son usage
spécifique.
Ça c'est un message perso que je vais
passer à un copain. Éric, il est bien ce
petit. Il est bien ce petit. Vous avez
un mot sur Assange Snowdon. Est-ce qu'on
leur accorde l'asile ? Est-ce qu'ils ont
bien fait ? Est-ce que les whistle
blower chez les hackers
nous on est censé être les peut-être
plus vous que moi maintenant être les
réels détenteurs de la sécurité
informatique ? Euh
ça vous fait mal un whisle blower ? Ça
vous fait du bien ? Est-ce que c'est
bien whistle blower ? Est-ce qu'il faut
pas ? Est-ce que Est-ce que quand on
est-ce que imaginez-vous, vous allez
dans une boîte bossée
et vous tombez sur un répertoire où il
fallait pas tomber dans un ordinateur de
quelqu'un qu'il fallait pas tomber et et
il y a des trucs un peu gloquissimes
dedans.
Euh mais vous êtes contraint de par
votre contrat à fermer votre bouche.
Vous faites quoi la journée ? Vous
faites oui avec la tête et la nuit vous
faites tiens tiens ou ou vous appelez la
police ? Vous faites quoi ?
Alors, tu as la réponse très pro et
contractuelle parce que aujourd'hui on a
des obligations là-dessus.
C'est ça.
Typiquement, alors on tombe sur des
sujets comme terrorisme, péo ou autre,
on a l'obligation de déclaration.
On peut même rompre l'accord de
confidentialité si ça arrive.
Après sur l'aspect lanceur d'alerte
comme Julien Assange avec des enjeux qui
enfin paraissent bien au-delà du petit
enfin du petit cage minim de on trouve
une situation touchy chez un client
c'est très niché et ça le concerne et
c'est pas impact aussi important que le
sujet à Sanche. Euh comment tu le gères
et autres ? Bah déjà, je pense que
ouais, tu prépares tes tu prépares ton
plan de secours de plan de secours de
plan de secours de plan de secours
et en fonction faudrait juger au cas par
cas mais si enfin si j'avais été à sa
place euh enfin je pense que je me
serais pas enfin j'aurais j'aurais fui
enfin tout simplement tu lâches la bombe
et tu fuis en fait voilà
c'est trop c'est pas c'est trop bineur
enfin je je je vais reprendre je je vais
reprendre le le contexte Mais
aujourd'hui en fait de du côté de de qui
est-ce qu'on se place pour si on prend
si on prend le cas Snowden par exemple ?
OK, très bien. Donc lui a décidé le
choix a pris le a pris la décision, a
fait le choix d'être le whistle blower,
donc d'être le lanceur d'alerte. Alors
je projette mais selon lui donc
effectivement il était nécessaire que le
peuple américain soit au courant des
problèmes de surveillance qu'il y avait.
Donc il a fait le choix de donner
l'information, donc le savoir, donc le
pouvoir au peuple.
Par contre euh et effectivement ça peut
être ça peut être lié aux problématiques
liées à la à la démocratie, à
l'ouvernance et cetera. C'est quand on
donne du pouvoir à un ensemble
d'individus, c'est qu'est-ce que cet
ensemble d'individus va faire de se
savoir derrière va comment est-ce qu'il
va l'utiliser s'il l'utilise et où le
cas échéant, bah comment est-ce que ça
va être utilisé par des tierces parties
qui sont malintentionnés. Ça c'est le
premier point. Le second point, c'est
dans ce cas, bah si on considère que la
population générale doit être
infantilisée et ou ne pas être au
courant de certaines opération de son
gouvernement, ça veut dire que bah on
place du coup la le savoir ou disons la
le décisions d'un gouvernement comme
étant un mal nécessaire pour le bien
d'une nation et ou de sa préservation.
Toi,
tu peux travailler en Chine directement.
Et dans ce cas, non mais effectivement
et dans ce cas en fait on se dit très
bien le gars qui va faire liquer les
documents va compromettre une opération
qui va compromettre des intérêts
nationaux derrière. Et donc au final
c'est pour moi c'est on revient purement
en terme d'éthique personnelle et de et
ou de curiosité aussi parce que ben en
l'occurrence c'était super sympa de
savoir ce qui s'est passé là-bas en
terme de curiosité personnelle. Par
contre, en terme d'éthique, au final,
bah c'est c'est c'est une c'est une une
scale, donc une échelle de gris. à quel
moment est-ce qu'on peut prendre le
risque de mettre en sécur alors selon
les les discours officiels en danger la
sécurité nationale
questionner ta conscience
pour remettre le pouvoir entre les mains
du peuple et est-ce et comment est-ce
qu'on le fait derrière et là-dessus je
vais pas partir sinon ça va être
beaucoup trop toch c'est des sujets qui
sont qui remontent à l'antiquité en fait
des moscratos le pouvoir au peuple
si tu as envie mec vas-y hein
mais non parce que effectivement si si
si on revient jusqu'à l'antiquité la
démocratie le pouvoir au peuple mais
initialement c'était pas le pouvoir au
peuple peuple, c'était les citoyens. Et
qu'est-ce qui était un citoyen ? C'était
quelqu'un qui initialement était
privilégié. Euh, il me semble que alors
je peut-être que je dis des bêtises,
hein, il me semble que du côté des
Founding Fazers au aux US, les pères
fondateurs aux États-Unis, c'était
c'était uniquement, il me semblait il me
semble qu'il fallait posséder à une
certaine époque de la terre pour avoir
justement ce droit de vote. C'est voilà
à quel moment est-ce que
les esclaves dessus ou pas ? Non,
ça voilà. Et en fait à quel moment qu'on
considère que le pouvoir est réellement
au peuple ? Et quel peuple est-ce que
c'est celui que qui va être considéré
comme étant éclairé pour voter ? Est-ce
que il y a des citoyens qu'il y a des
citoyens de seconde zone ? C'est des ce
sont des sujets qui sont beaucoup trop
complexes pour dire "Ah ben moi, j'aime
bien, moi j'aime pas,
j'aime tes nuances."
Je voudrais par contre revenir sur un un
sujet. Tu as posé la question de savoir
si le cas Julien Assange ça fait mal et
l'asile politique. Il y en a un qui m'a
particulièrement marqué, c'est Aaron
Schwartz. Ah ouais, the internet boy
Aaron qui avait fait liquer une base de
données de cours, c'était du MIT.
Ouais.
Ensuite, il a été avait été privatisé,
c'était de la ressource censée être
publique et accessible à tout le monde
qui a été privatisé par des enfin par
des entreprises du coup avec un business
model qui est tu vas payer un de Mirin
pour avoir accès à la connaissance.
Euh et effectivement, il s'est pris neuf
chefs d'accusation
parce qu'il servait d'exemple.
Il s il a fini par se suicider. Ouais.
Et en plus il s'était enfin sauf erreur
cfondateur de Redit, il a revendu il a
revendu au bout d'un an. Euh il a réussi
à porter l'annihilation de Sopa Pipa à
l'époque aussi sur la la répression de
la
Qu'est-ce que c'est Sopa Pipa ? Euh
alors c'était des tentatives de légis de
de tentative de cadrage
de la liberté d'expression et de non
contrôle quai internet aux États-Unis.
et je m'arrête là. Je rentrerai pas plus
dans le détail parce que les tenants les
tenants je les tiens pas mais je sais
que c'est enfin c'était majeur et c'est
enfin c'était pas le même genre d'ennui
qu'on a nous avec du petit Adopi ou des
tentatives de régulation qui qui n'ont
rien à voir quoi. Et en l'occurrence, il
a porté tous ces dossiers là. s'est
battu pour ses convictions, pour la
liberté du net à 14 piges. Bon là je je
sais un résumé et de sa bio et du film
The Internet Boy qui est sur Netflix je
crois et qui présente enfin qui présente
sa vie avec les témoignages de son
entourage sa famille à 14 piges. Il
était dans le working group qui a défini
les flux RSS qui aujourd'hui est-ce qui
vous sert sur votre navigateur sur votre
smartphone à lire les news quoi. et il
s'est ramené, il était dans le working
group et l'anecdote c'était il a pu se
ramener parce que c'était le seul mec
qui était avec des des gars de plus de
30 piges qui bossaient à fond sur le
dossier. C'était le seul gars qui a dit
"Oui, je viendrai à la à la réunion au
day au launching day, enfin au jour de
lancement où ils sont fait une bouffe en
disant je vais demander autorisation à
maman avant quoi." Et son histoire est
super triste quoi.
Est triste à mort.
Euh question. Y a-t-il un système de
chiffrement qui leur résiste ?
Alors, vous êtes pas obligé de répondre,
d'accord ? Surtout si vous pétez de la
US 256.
Tu as l'aspect, de toute façon, tu as la
notion de chiffrement militaire qui
varie d'un pays à l'autre
à partir de quand c'est considéré comme
illégal ? Si je si je puis je me
permettre la blague déplacée, il me
semble que les Américains disent que
le grade militaire c'est le lowest beer,
donc c'est celui qui a fait l'offre la
plus basse. Mais ça ça c'était la blague
non corpo. Par contre, par rapport au
chiffrement aujourd'hui, l'idée c'est
d'avoir des protocoles cryptographiques
qui sont vus, revus, audité par des
paires avec des personnes qui ont une
expertise mathématique qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas la nôtre
notamment une expertise algorithmique
n'est pas forcément la nôtre. Par
contre, bah les on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure avec le avec le cas de Truc
Crypt, l'implémentation parfois de fait
volontaire de faiblesse cryptographique,
c'est le plus simple, c'est fait tout le
temps.
C'est ça.
Et donc je te pose une question si tu as
fini.
Je t'en prie. Je t'en prie. Je te pose
une question. Peut-on sécuriser Windows
? Donc là, ça va vous faire marrer.
Comprenez-vous que la DJA, le Pentagone
français est mis ce type d'OS sur
certaines bécanes ?
Ben, ils fournissent même aujourd'hui
avec les acteurs avec lesquels ils
travaillent, leurs prestataires de
services et leurs sous-traitants des
exigences cyberes. Et dans les exigences
cyber sur le cas Windows, il y a ce
qu'on appelle du hardening qui est
demandé. Donc c'est des mesures
techniques à appliquer sur le système
d'exploitation pour renforcer son niveau
de sécurité. Il y a plein de comités qui
travaillent à l'échelle européenne. Tuas
le C, je crois que c'est CIS, c'est
européen mais j'ai peur de dire une
connerie mais c'est le je je veux bien
une double vérif là-dessus qui en tout
cas met à disposition des benchmark et
des guides référentiels sur en gros tuas
tuas tout dou list avec les 200 mesures
de comment je renforce mon Windows pour
avoir un niveau d'exigence. Donc je vire
les services inutiles. Le compte invité
du système d'exploitation, ça sert à
rien qu' reste. Je mets en place une
politique de enfin de complexité de mot
de passe. Bref, tout ce que tu dois
faire pour avoir un niveau de
renforcement. Et aujourd'hui, tous ces
référentiels chacun un peu les siens et
mais en l'occurrence nos corps armés ont
leur ont leurs exigences propres et qui
se basent et qui que tu vas retrouver
dans d'autres référentiels en fait. Mais
ils vont faire un agrégat de tout ça.
Ils vont dire le niveau d'exigence, on
le place là. Et la mise en conformité,
c'est tu es capable de passer la
checklist qu'on va te donner.
Je vais lire deux trois questions à la
volée. Vous choisissez celle que vous
voulez parce qu'on arrive bientôt à la
fin. Et j'attrape n'importe quelle
ligne.
Alors, vous avez quelle formation, quel
parcours scolaire ? On l' évoqué très
rapidement. On peut faire une petite
synthèse qu'on aime bien communiquer
dessus. que ça montre le le fait que le
que le milieu est ouvert tant qu'on a le
bon mindset et maintenant avecat
d'esprit
le bon état d'esprit et avec maintenant
la tournure que prenne que prend la
cyber en France. Boris, je te laisse bac
STI DUT G2I euh 1 an et demi d'école
d'inge et c'est tout.
Euh bac scientifique, prépa, pharmacine
ratée, euh 4 années dans une école
d'ingénieur de seconde zone et Rash kit.
Alors des questions
sauf mon respect pour certains des
enseignants.
C'est c'est tu veux donner le nom de la
l'école d'ingé c'est deité publique mais
c'était c'était sympa. Il y a certains
qui étaient vraiment porteurs du projet
mais
mais 90 % c'était de la merde. C'est ça.
Ouais.
Donc il y a des questions, ils font des
blagues. Donc ARM c'est pas de l'open
source
euh acide nuucléique.
Non non la boîte qui s'est fait à moitié
manger par les Chinois.
sur l'architecture ARM.
Ah oui, l'architecture ARM aussi,
pardon. Autant pour moi. Il y a
il y a trop d'accroisement.
Non, c'est c'est pas open source mais
c'est une architecture en fait. C'est
pas une question.
Un mot sur la pénurie de certains
composants informatiques.
Ah bah ça, on l'a vu quand on a besoin
de s'acheter du matos pour bosser.
Ouais.
Ah bah tiens,
c'est catastrophique. Ah il demande même
maintenant il faut faire il faut les
rappeler au téléphone pour avoir un
devis juste pour deux procos. Enfin un
proco, ça passe dans le panier. de
proco, faut rappeler, faut demander.
C'est et je pense que côté crypto, faut
pas se mentir non plus, il y a une
incidence
le Boeing qui lives graphique, c'est pas
un mythe, c'est une réalité quoi.
Alors, le cloud Microsoft, Microsoft 365
SharePoint est utilisé par quasiment
toutes les entreprises. C'est sécurisé
pour l'interrogation. Mais tu connais
déjà la réponse avant de la poser la
question Paul.
Bah, il suffit de il faut taper CV.
Attends, attends, attends. C'est
sécurisé. une marge de manœuvre pour les
entreprises pour améliorer la sécurité.
Bah, ils produisent des guides mais qui
sont issus de leur propre référentiel.
Si vous ouvrez effectivement internet,
vous tapez euh donc CVE 2021 euh
Microsoft ou Azure, vous aurez le
listing de tout ce qui concerne leurs
produits, les failles et les incidences
et les impacts. Euh mais en
l'occurrence, vous êtes enfin on
là-dessus, on est dépendant de l'éditeur
logiciel qui fournit le service.
En fait, il y a a y a deux zones. Il y a
la marge de sécurité sur laquelle
l'utilisateur peut progresser dans le
cadre du logiciel. Donc c'est
généralement c'est le guide de
renforcement et l'autre partie c'est
celle qui dépend pas de lui bah c'est le
logiciel en lui-même.
Puis euh sur la l'approche qui décrivait
Victor tout à l'heure sur la protection
par couche, est-ce qu'il y a une
légitimité à exposer par exemple son
serveur exchange sur lequel bah la boîte
gère tous ses mails ? Est-ce qu'il y a
une légitimité à l'exposer sur internet
ou de conditionner son accès uniquement
par un VPN déjà qui permet d'accéder à
l'entreprise ? C'est plus une
problématique d'architecture que de
enfin on cloisonne quand malheureusement
on n pas la maîtrise sur tout le
périmètre.
Question d'ailleurs qui est très
intéressante. Nos élites françaises
entre parenthèses politiques n'ont-elles
pas volontairement creusé notre
incompétence numérique ? Alors
volontairement c'est lui notamment par
le biais de programme scolaires pauvres
et d'un manque de formation depuis deux
décennies.
Ça va être dur d'avoir une réponse
corporate là-dessus. Euh alors, on a
fait le choix, mais ça veut pas dire que
c'est une vérité absolue. Euh
aujourd'hui, même lorsqu'on échange avec
les écoles qui nous demande d'intervenir
pour des sujets cyber, dans certains cas
de figure, on reçoit une trame de
programme qui vient de Paris. Je ne sais
plus quelle est l'entité qui l'imit,
mais qui en gros va effectivement
définir des objectifs pédagogiques en
plus d'un, je dirais, d'un fil
conducteur.
Ce fil conducteur dans 4 quoi 4 sur 5
quoi ? Ouais. 80 % on peut prendre le
Oui, je pense.
Euh n'est pas à jour n'est pas alors
n'est pas à jour et à l'état de l'art de
ce qui se fait dans le domaine
professionnel, ça peut se comprendre
puisque finalement ce sont des étudiants
qui veulent monter en compétence. Par
contre, sur les outils et l'approche
trop théorisé, pas forcément axé sur des
sur de la pratique haute, euh on est le
premier à aller puisque il nous faut
plus de flexibilité, il faut changer les
méthodes d'apprentissage. C'est pas
suffisant. C'est pas en leur en leur
enfin j'ai rien contre l'ANC, j'ai rien
contre les autorités de régulation mais
typiquement commencer un cours
d'introduction à la cyber en leur
déroulant tous les aspects normatifsah
c'estouffable
enfin on va les déprimer
c'est ça
nous on on se on s'ennuie
c'est ce qu'il y a de pire avec la cœur
et qui enfin il ils aiment pas quo ils
apprennent pas ça les stimule pas enfin
c'est l'approche pédagogique sur lequel
il faudrait faire l'effort parce que les
ressources on les a elles sont gratuites
elles sont sur Google Mais c'est
l'aspect pédagogique de comment on
suscite la curiosité, comment on les
fait s'intéresser, comment on
Elles sont pas sur Google, elles sont
sur internet. [__]
merde,
je t'ai coupé.
Mais comment tu suscites des patients ?
En fait, c'est plutôt ça sur ça qu'il
faudrait mettre l'effort de comment tu
intéresses à des sujets, mais pas que la
cyber, même tout le reste. Quand le
gamin, il arrive à l'école et il se dit
"Ah ouais, j'ai découvert ce métier là
et du coup je vais partir là-dedans
parce que j'ai eu un attrait, j'ai
essayé, ça m'a plu, je veux y aller."
Enfin, on est passé par des
Attends juste un détail. Vous avez
commencé à bidouiller à partir de quoi
et pourquoi ?
Euh,
je crois que le premier PC à la maison,
c'était 5e. Tu
avais pas de tune pour acheter des jeux
?
Euh non, non, on avait une chance
monstrueuse. C'était vraiment sur le
prix, il y a dû y avoir une erreur.
C'était à Carrefour en plus à l'époque.
Et euh c'était pour télécharger euh
illégalement une ROM de Pokémon de 5 MCT
sur un émulateur Game Boy Advance euh
qui mettait sur une ligne 56k, ça
mettait bien plus d'une heure. Je crois
que c'était 1h5 kbps 56 kb seconde.
Ouais,
ça mettait 1h05. Et quand ça si
quelqu'un décroché entre-temps, tu
devais relancer le téléchargement.
Tu nous fais le petit bruit de
connexion.
J'aurais pas le faire. Je me souviens
même plus.
Un mot sur la suprématie quantique.
Alors là, aucune idée.
Tu maîtrises ?
Ouais. Alors, vu le risque potentiel par
rapport à tout ce qui est aspect
chiffrement et même puissance de calcul,
oui, c'est extrêmement important de se
pencher dessus. Est-ce qu'il faut le
faire maintenant au vu du chantier cyber
qu'on a déjà ? C'est une question
géopolitique et d'ailleurs c'est une
question d'affectation de ressources
parce que la tech est pas mature. C'est
une union de savoir-faire unique de
plusieurs pays et généralement de
secteurs privés qui sont rattachés à
d'autres entités nationales.
Si ça pète le chiffrement, ça apportera
pas d'une certaine manière aussi en même
temps la le nouveau standard adopté sur
comment est-ce qu'on gère le le la
gestion du secret ? question internet.
Euh et puis euh on va passer à des
questions un tout petit peu moins
techniques, mais ça histoire de pas
perdre la moitié de des gens qui nous
regardent. Nos ingénieurs réseaux ne
devraient-ils pas réfléchir à un nouveau
protocole de communication ? Le
protocole TCPIP n'est-il pas obsolète ?
Les Français ne devraient ne devraient
pas innover là-dessus. Point
d'interrogation, on a déjà pas fini la
migration IPv6.
Oh [__] c'est chaud.
Alors, il faudrait qu'il retrouve chaud.
Et en plus, il y a un bordel monstrueux
sur les épidem sur les coups des R
jipv4. C'est c'est enfin c'est devenu
une approche enfin c'est limite
spéculatif. Maintenant
il faudrait qu'il retrouve il y a un
petit panel de BD qui s'appelle XKCD. Il
y en a un qui est exactement sur ce
thème là c'est voilà il y a 18 standards
concurrentiels aujourd'hui il nous
faudrait un standard concur un standard
qui les englobe tous. Très bien.
Maintenant il y a 19 standards
concurrentiels.
Ça joue à quoi comme jeu vidéo les
hackur éthiques ?
Strike mais je suis pas très bon. Vous
avez le temps de jouer en ce moment,
vous avez pas le temps.
On a en 6 mois, on a réussi à redémarrer
un 20h d'un Resident Evil 6 et de se
faire 4 heur de Counter Strike.
C'est pas une blague. Mais sur le
Discord, ils ont repris, ils sont tous,
ils ont il y en a certains, ils ont fait
"Bon, c'est bon, j'ai fait mon j'ai fait
mon test sur le bug Munti, je me mets un
petit peu en en friche là." Ils sont sur
Dofus en ce moment.
Question : "Bug bounty inclut en moyenne
combien il gagne ?
Euh, tu veux être transparent ou quoi ?
Alors, hyper basse comme question, moi
je m'en fiche.
OK. Après, au niveau des collaborateurs,
on fait le choix d'être transparent.
Donc, on se sort 2300 € net avant un pot
sur le avant prélèvement la source. Euh
la boîte fait un chiffre d'affaires
qu'on communique à nos salariés euh
qu'on communiquera peut-être de manière
publique lorsqu'on aura fait notre
premier bilan et euh dans tous les cas
les salaires des salariés seront indaxés
sur notre chiffre d'affaires
et vous avez les deux plus petits
salaires.
Ou on paye plus nos salaries. Oui, c'est
la stratégie. Après bon, c'est normal,
on construit quelque chose.
Comment vraiment protéger ces appareils
électroniques ? Quelle plateforme
favoriser ?
Une cage deadé.
Appareil électronique dans quel sens ?
Non. Ouais, c'est vra par rapport Non,
mais par contre un peu plus un peu plus
de contexte, c'est parce que c'est
vraiment toute l'IT du robot de cuisine
à au reste enfin alors idéalement c'est
on segmente, on isole et donc on on
contient, on protège. Donc effectivement
le robot de cuisine qu'on a acheté et
qu'on reçoit d'une usine douteuse et
dont ne connaît pas le firmware mais qui
vous propose de vous connecter au rés
interne effectivement
souvent ça alors bah expérience perso je
l'ai à la maison il n'est pas connecté
mais par contre est-ce que bah il sait
pas de se connecter chez moi j'en sais
rien j'en sais
problème c'est pour monsieur et madame
tout le monde là-dessus tu peux pas leur
demander effectivement de mettre un
routeur de faire un de faire un
sous-réseau séparé de faire une approche
sans boxée on met tout dedans un
sous-réseau poubelle dans lequel on va
voir les éléments sur lesquels on n pas
la maîtrise sécu. Donc pour monsieur
madame tout le monde sans appétence
technique, c'est de commencer par ne pas
en acheter. C'est si ou alors du
standard frigo qui ne parle pas, qui
n'affiche pas s reste de la bière un
micro même si bon ça à la rigueur c'est
discutable mais un microondessage
regarder
le le micro non connecté. Voilà, c'est
parce que des micros sur les barres de
son, c'est quand même magnifique les les
Alexa et tout. Mais
c'est pour faire du OK Google,
c'est ça ? OK Google.
Mais c'est le prix du confort, on bouge
pas du canapé. Et
alors, on va faire un OK Google chez
tout le monde, d'accord ? OK Google.
OK Google.
On a essayé le téléphone à côté.
Une question, qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de la société de surveillance, de la loi
du la loi renseignement, le contrôle sur
les chats, chat contrôle et ainsi de
suite.
Est-ce
que société de surveillance,
est-ce qu'on peut servir de cas extrêmes
pour légitimer une
violation alors plus ou moins mesurée de
la liberté des individus ? Euh
ça
moi je suis je suis enfin intimement ça
me fait enfin je suis dans deux
positions à titre personnel et dans mon
univers égoïste me considérant sans
prendre en considération les autres.
Oui, ça me fait chier parce que c'est un
accès à à ce qui m'est propre, ce qui
m'est cher, à des valeurs, le l'aspect
euh je n'ai rien à cacher, c'est enfin
on est d'accord, on a tous quelque chose
à cacher ou qu'on a pas envie de surtout
vu la surexposition des réseaux sociaux
euh et les dérives que ça peut prendre,
aide qu' a dessus,
c'est ça. Donc c'est pas parce que vous
n'avez rien à cacher que la
surexposition sur un réseau n'aboutira
pas sur quelque chose qui va vous
toucher ou vous impacter sur un format
de harcèlement ou autre. Et en
contrepartie, donc si je me considère
tout seul égoïstement, ça me fait chier.
Sauf que la légitimité à devoir
surveiller certains scénarios critiques
qui a donné cours à des drames nationaux
comme on les a connu, tu te retrouves
avec deux enfin
paix à leurs hommes. tu te retrouves
avec deux mondes en opposition de phase
et dans ce cas-là, bah
j'avoue que moi je fais le choix laisse
de me dire "Bah fuck it, tant pis euh si
c'est regardé, c'est regardé et puis euh
mais dans tous les cas ça sert à
l'intérêt public." Voilà, j'ai ce point
de vue là.
J'ouvre une parenthèse qui n'a rien à
voir. Si un jour vous êtes victime de
cyberharcèlement, n'hésitez pas à porter
plainte. Si vous êtes victime de docing
ou qu'on publie des informations sur
vous privé,
Ouais. qui vous touchent, qui vous
peuvent vous mettre en danger. Vous
portez plainte tout de suite. Les peines
ont été augmentées. N'hésitez plus,
n'hésitez plus. Et surtout quand vous
avez une petite bande de petits connards
qui s qui s'amusent à se mettre en
groupe sur vous et à vous insulter, vous
harceler, à vous faire des misères, vous
allez à la gendarmerie nationale avec
des captures d'écran et vous portez
plainte il presto. Faut que ça cesse.
Bien sûr là-dessus, on pourrait même
rajouter parce on fait très
exceptionnellement des particuliers en
probono
vraiment le je me suis fait enfin je me
suis fait dépouiller le compte, j'ai été
à la gendarmerie, ça a fini chez le
procureur de la République qui a classé
en je sais plus si c'est en 108 ou en
non lieu. Je crois que c'est en non
lieu, faute de preuve. C'est soit 108
faute de preuve, soit non lieu, faute de
preuve.
Maintenant à l'échelle nationale en cas
de dépôt de plainte gendarmerie, il y a
à minima à l'échelle régionale un
référent cyber police et derrière
l'escalade d'après, c'est les dossiers
qui partent chez ce qu'on appelle les
Ntech Napostrophech. C'est vers ces
acteurs-là qu'il faut se rediriger. Ils
ont très peu de bandes passantes parce
qu'ils sont sur des sujets
malheureusement graves. Les particuliers
sont un peu les laisser pour compte et
les délaissés mais euh dans leur volonté
c'est d'améliorer pour pouvoir plus
facilement gérer ces ce genre de dérive
sur le net. Ouais. Mais c'est la marche
à suivre et c'est aujourd'hui quand on
bosse avec eux sur certains dossiers
c'est ce qu'ils aimeraient que ce soit
enfin le process qui devrait être
adopté.
Dit faites ça. OK. Euh un avis sur tous
anti Covid,
l'application
passé au cri du bug bounty.
Elle est passé en public sur le bug
buunty, je crois.
Ça a même été médiatisé. Ouais. Pas plus
regardé que ça parce que la techno était
pas très enfin j'aimais pas trop la
techno. Je sais pas si tu as regardé
toi.
Non non plus. J'ai pas pas été fun.
Après, ça a bien été rincé hein parce
que ça a été rincé en deux temps et euh
il y a eu par contre une polémique il y
a pas longtemps non sur des histoire de
tracking qui euh tracking de multis
origines permettait de faire du
recroisement. Mais j'ai pas j'ai pas
regardé le les spécificités du dossier.
Allez, une petite dernière de l'outre
poutre.
Est-ce que le fait que l'Union
européenne veuille forcer l'USBC au
détriment du Thunderbolt d'Apple est une
bonne chose ? une seule un seul standard
pour le pour les rassembler tous et dans
les commodités liées quit de
l'obsolescence programmée de ces ewte
selon eux me rajouter pas une ligne qui
saute [__] selon eux a-t-elle une
politique commune crédible pour contrer
les menaces étrangères
le lien entre le thunder le thunderbolt
et les menaces étrangères j'ai peut-être
pas forcément complètement suivi pour le
câble quoi. Ouais, voilà. Enfin, par
contre, effectivement, l'idée c'est de
l'idée d'avoir un standard unique, ben
oui, c'est hyper pratique par rapport à
l'interopérabilité et effectivement par
rapport aux problématiques d'ob
d'obsolescence qu'on peut considérer
comme étant programmé, j'ai pas
forcément le lien direct de s'échappe
d'une typologie de matériel, mais par
contre, c'est bien de d'avoir des
protocoles qui permettent d'échanger, de
réparer plus facilement et donc au
final, ça rejoint la notion d'op
hardware qu'on avait aujourd'hui. Est-ce
que aujourd'hui on peut le porter et
l'imposer sur à l'échelle internationale
? Ben non, ça va être difficile. Des
standards au niveau software, ce sont
des consortiums interentreprises et
internationaux qui travaillent ensemble
sur des dizaines et des vingtaines
d'années pour toucher des pour pousser
des des standards. Mais au final, sur
l'implémentation de ces standards là,
très souvent on observe un sacré delta.
Donc c'est quand même assez difficile de
d'uniformiser. Est-ce que j'espère queon
puisse tendre vers une uniformisation de
l'interopérabilité sur du hardware ?
Oui, ça a une plusvalue technologique,
c'est une plusvalue bidouilleur, c'est
une plusvalue écologique. Donc oui, ça
peut être intéressant de le faire mais
c'est un chantier.
Euh on parlera on vous fera revenir sur
les techniques de hacking en détail plus
tard. Euh un mot sur les anonymous.
Ça non, on a on a vu de tout sur le
sujet quoi.
Ouais. Tu as gardé ton circuit imprimé
quand tu étais en IUT ?
Ouais. Qui c'est qui a demandé ça ?
Fais-moi ton malin.
C'était premier premier PCB en DUT.
Ouais. Pour faire du spouff de badfid
sur du M407 4107. Ouais.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? trois
livres chacun
sur
Victor n'importe lequel le problème
c'est que j'ai des tutos PDF
tout sujet confondu euh pour Oh là alors
euh envie
le bouquin qui m'a mis qui m'a mis un
petit peu en jambe j'avais 14 ans,
j'avais piqué je sais plus 10 balles
parci 10 balles par là pour aller à la
Virgin et m'acheter
Hacking the Art of Exploitation par John
Erikson version 2. une bien référence
qui n'est plus du tout à jour mais qui
en l'occurrence m'a permis avec le petit
CD la la distribution Live Linux dessus
d'effacer l'ordinateur familial les les
photos de famille et le logiciel pour la
pour la caméra. Tu as dû te faire
arracher là.
C'est pas toi, toi, c'est pas toi. Comme
ça,
c'était le live. Ah moi je pensais qu'à
l'époque un dual boot c'était coupé
vraiment le disco dur en de
c'était c'était une bonne référence,
c'était très sympa.
Euh sur la partie technique web
application hacker handbook version 2
qui même s'il est un petit peu obsolète,
ça reste quand même toujours une
excellente une excellente ressource pour
se former et sur un format un petit peu
plus général et pour se donner un air
cultivé, je dirais un ouvrage de
philosophie grecque.
Non, par contre c'est vraiment enfin je
trouve ça vraiment intéressant par
contre de de lire un petit peu de fil au
grec après est-ce que je j'ai la
prétention d'avoir lu un ouvrage de A à
Z ?
Tu as fini ?
Oui, je t'en prie.
Pendant pendant que Bris réfléchit
encore, je te pose une question. Leur
avis sur la la protection
d'infrastructure critique côté comme les
réseaux électriques par exemple le
risque probabilité d'occurrence d'un
scénario de menace type blackout.
Alors
ça c'est Éric Filiol qui avait fait une
grosse étude comme ça. Il voulait aller
la présenter aux États-Unis puis là DGS
lui a dit "Tu restes à la maison parce
que sinon tu vas pas revenir."
Alors pour moi ça enfin ça rejoint le
champ très vaste de tout ce qu'on
appelle l'ICS CAD donc système de
contrôle industriel et donc du coup bah
qui sont appliqués effectivement à
toutes ces infrastructures qui sont
critiques. Aujourd'hui, je sais qu'il y
a eu une il y a eu des des des
conférences et des compétitions de
hacking notamment hébergé alors qui a
été organisé il me semble par le
gouvernement turc il y a un an un an et
demi qui reproduisent une
l'infrastructure d'une ville et qui en
fait pousse les à cœur à essayer de
détruire la ville sur un sur un format
très gamifié. Donc oui, il y a des
scénarios qui sont qui peuvent être
réalisés. Euh les systèmes de contrôle
industriel, on les a observés et c'est
quand même assez documenté, sont
gérement obsolètes, vulnérables. Et la
typologie de vulnérabilité qu'on y qu'on
retrouve dessus, ce sont les failles
d'il y a 20 25 30 ans qui sont pas
forcément toujours patchés parce que
c'était pas la priorité qui veulent euh
qui n'ont pas été résolus, qui n'ont pas
été voilà fix qui n'ont pas été résolus.
Et là-dessus, il me semble que euh en
tout cas du côté du côté des Américains,
ils ont ils ont des ils ont des des
scénarios de reproduction des crises
cyber. Et est-ce qu'on a des impacts
aujourd'hui dans le monde réel ?
Oui, cette année ou l'année passée aux
États-Unis, il y a eu une compromission
dans un château d'eau aux États-Unis sur
l'augmentation de la quantité de soude,
il me semble dans le dans le château
d'eau. Tu me dis souviens pipeline, non
? pas longtemps.
Et alors les pipelines coloniaux
effectival pipelines,
cit une blague ça
euh là-dessus où bon bah les je pense
que ils sont ils sont évaporés coup ils
ont dit non ben en fait finalement on n
plus là, vous avez peut-être peur de se
prendre un coup de démocratie
américaine
plus récemment et et a vérifié euh le
secteur agroalimentaire américain avec
notalement sur la production de maïs. On
a vu ça sur les sur les les gars qui
font de la veille sur sur tout ce qui
est acteur de menace avec
potentiellement des impacts sur la
supply chain. Enfin oui, aujourd'hui il
y a des il y a des il y a des scénarios
de compromission. Pour l'instant on n
pas encore vu le scénario catastrophe de
la ville qui s'éteint. Par contre on a
des on commence à avoir du
Ouais, on l'imagine bien et on a pas mal
de scénarios annexes.
Je comme Bris a toujours pas trouvé ce
bout je te repose une question. Bonjour.
Quel est leur avis ? et arrêtez de poser
des questions. Quel est leur avis sur la
nécessité de la souveraineté des
équipements informatiques et plus
particulièrement de sécurité
souveraineté versus efficacité des
solutions ?
C'est même plus une question
d'efficacité à l'heure à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui. C'est juste une c'est
alors oui sauf si on considère qu'un bon
un bon 30 ou 40 ans dans le passé c'est
une paire d'efficacité. Aujourd'hui,
c'est le niveau de complexité de la
technologie, l'aspect cloud source, les
brevets de la tech spécifique. Tout à
l'heure, on l'a évoqué très rapidement,
la tech qui permet justement de faire
les de fabriquer les machines qui
fabriquent les circuits imprimés. C'est
c'est du c'est du concentré d'innovation
qui a été investi à une époque par des
conglomérats des d'entreprises et de
nations. Aujourd'hui, avoir une
souveraineté complète sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne de production, est-ce que
c'est réalisable ? Non. Enfin, on le
voit aujourd'hui sur la sur les sur les
crises de la supply chain. Il suffit
qu'on ait un ou deux acteurs qui partent
un petit peu en caraf et au niveau
mondial, on a plus de on a on a plus
d'équipement. Donc est-ce que ça serait
bien dans son monde ? Ça le discours de
tout à l'heure, c'est si tu as pas la
maîtrise sur l'ensemble de ton
informatique ou de ton système
d'information, ce que tu maîtrises, tu
peux te permettre de l'exposer. Ce que
tu ne sais pas, tu le cloisonnes et tu
l'enfermes et tu le restreins. Et avec
une approche
quand il y a un doute, il n'y a pas de
doute. OK,
c'est ça.
Tu as trouvé tes bouquins ou ?
Ouais. Non mais j'étais pas j'avais
trouvé deux j'en ai deux qui m'ont
marqué. Le premier ça a été quand
j'étais candid vraiment candid dans
cyber et je me suis dit je le finis et
c'est bon après je trouve un job.
C'était le le cliché le bouquin sur
starting starting metploit ou quelque
chose comme ça. Il y a du métasploit
dedans dans le titre parce que c'est
c'est une boîte à outils qu'on utilise
quand on démarre, quand on découvre,
quand on veut tester même enfin même
encore, on l'utilise aujourd'hui avec
des des modules perso.
Et globalement la couverture pour ceux
qui le chercheront, c'est fond vert avec
une clé dessus et il est je crois qu'il
est sur enfin vous pouvez trouver la
référence sur un grand site de vente en
ligne en moins de 24 heures là. Et le
deuxième c'était technique de
manipulation pas pour manipuler les gens
mais sur lequel on s'est fortement
inspiré. Aujourd'hui, quand on part en
audite physique, en intrusion physique,
on revient quand même avec des sacrés
souvenirs, des sacrés des sacrés
anecdotes et euh en l'occurrence, on
utilise pas mal dans ce qu'on fait.
Qu'est-ce que tu entends par technique
d'intrusion ?
C'est le trisème.
Et le trisème, j'ai pas parce qu'après
en fait, je suis très peu bouquin
papier. Je vais m'endormir dessus alors
que le PDF, l'écran tient éveillé.
Euh, pilule bleue, pilule rouge, non. Eh
euh un conseil à la génération des vieux
cons qui n'ont jamais eu de smartphone
ni de portable.
Demander aux petits enfants.
Combler le fossé intergénérationnel.
Mais c'est beau, c'est très très beau.
Ça t'est venu comme ça d'un coup.
Alors un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, un quelque chose qui sera
impérissable, qui restera comme une
bouteille à la mer sur les réseaux.
Victor
comprendre d'où ça vient. Alors c'est
enfin j'ai vraiment essayé de de le
formuler de la manière la plus vulgarisé
possible avec les 5 secondes que j'ai
que j'ai pu avoir pour réfléchir. Mais
euh
si tu veux en prendre plus, tu peux. Le
le monde évolue vite, les technologies
évoluent vite, les effets de mode
évoluent vite et quand on est jeune, on
est dans un dans une bulle et cette
bulle là, elle est elle est constituée
de nos interactions sociales. Ces
interaction sociales là, malheureusement
et heureusement définissent une partie
de notre personnalité de la manière dont
on va évoluer. Ces interactions sociales
sont aujourd'hui beaucoup modulées par
la tech, par les réseaux sociaux, par
les tendances queon peut voir passer
maintenant sur l'outil qui est internet.
Et pour moi, il faut être capable un
moment de de de de dire stop de déco et
de se dire bon bah attends
de déconnecter
de déconnecter.
Pourquoi ça va comme ça ? Pourquoi ça va
dans dans ce sens-là ? À qui profite le
crime ou va l'argent ? Et derrière c'est
OK, très bien, j'ai envie de me former.
Bah attends, stop. Comment ça marche ?
D'où ça vient ? On va on va on va
reprendre step by step pour faire un
clin d'œil
au meilleur conseil que m'a jamais
donné.
Euh ce serait plus pour les futures
générations dans le milieu du hacking.
Euh aujourd'hui, ce qu'on a enfin ce que
notre carrière professionnelle est
devenue, comment on a pu y accéder ? On
l'a dit tout au début, donc en plus ça
fait le rattachement, c'est grâce aux
générations d'avant, même si c'était il
y a que 10 ans, 15 ans, 20 ans et les
prémisses remontent dans les années 60
ou 60 comme l'évoquait Victor.
Ce qu'on est en train d'essayer de
faire, c'est dans ce même état d'esprit,
c'est-à-dire le partage,
je dirais l'agrégation, enfin le fait de
regrouper, de d'alimenter cette
communauté de manière bienveillante
sans se prendre la tête, sans partir
dans des guerres d'ego qui aujourd'hui
sont inutiles. En fait, on n'orte,
il y en a de plus en plus. C'est dingue.
Moi à mon époque, il y avait pas ça.
On perd certains aspects du partage. On
est content parce que en l'occurrence on
suit on suit un peu les différentes
écoles et on a on trouve on voit très
vite les profs qui sont d'ancien à cœur
qu'on crée des promos, ils arrivent aux
events, ils éclatent tout. Enfin, tu
vois qu'il y a il y a cette cohésion de
groupe. Les mecs sont motivés, ils
arrivent enfin ils ont bossé, tu vois,
tu sens que et ils arrivent ils arrivent
sur le terrain, ils sont face à des
professionnels qui trollent, qui
tuntent, enfin qui donc qui trollent,
qui font des blagues de mauvais goût,
qui envoient des provocations douteuses.
Et pourtant, Infiné, à la fin, c'est les
étudiants et la nouvelle génération qui
partagent ces valeurs de passion,
d'humilité qui bah qui sort victorieuse
de l'événement. Euh c'est une symbolique
récente qu'on a vu au fic mais qui
conclut enfin qui relève bien de du
moode et de l'état d'esprit dans lequel
il faut être et euh ce vers quoi on
aimerait même si ça fait un peu les
vieux darons à l'heure mais de se dire
euh si vous pouvez perdurer cette ces
ces ces valeurs-là c'est enfin c'est
c'est tout ce qu'il y a à faire en fait
il y a pas besoin de rajouter de
négativité tout simplement.
Step by step c'est une référence à quoi
? Euh à chaque fois qu'on s'engueule ou
euh quand on est face à un projet
compliqué, je lui dis on fait étape par
étape. Tu sais quand tu as une nébuleuse
de d'emmerde euh bah tu prends un tout
petit bout, tu le règles et puis tu
passes au petit bout et puis étape par
étape.
Messieurs, merci. à toi.
[Musique]